I used to struggle a lot with
manifesting just the idea of it I would
watch videos on it and I didn't
understand what they were saying what
are they saying I don't understand the
words that are coming out of your mouth
and I would rewind him to watch you guys
like I don't get it I don't understand
it seemed weird silly not good enough
for me to just sit on a couch and think
about money coming into your wallet or
whatever it was that you're trying to
manifest you got to go do something that
in law of attraction action is at the
end of Attraction like you got to go off
and do the work the first thing that I
realized is very scientific is from the
reticular activating systems it's part
of your brain that decides what to pay
attention to and what to not pay
attention to there are so many things
that are happening right now all around
you that you are not paying attention to
most things your brain filters out and
only filter in the things that you
should care about so for example
um you know what color are your socks
today most things you're ignoring
because there's no possible way to pay
attention to everything hey it's Nina
Carmichael and we
are probably the most ambitious person
in your circle but you know you're
capable of much more and you get that
Push by surrounding yourself with the
best so today let's learn from one of
the best my husband Evan Carmichael and
our take on his top 10 rules for Success
enjoy
so what does your brain actually pay
attention to well the reticular
activating system
will choose to say okay you've set an
intention right I want to pay attention
to X and now all of a sudden you're
going to see that more often I I'm I
just bought a house so in that process
we started paying attention a lot more
to houses so one of the things I noticed
was the for sale sign here where I may
have not noticed that as much in the
past but because thinking house boom now
I'm paying attention to the for sale
sign you ever notice when you buy a car
you start seeing that car everywhere
right or even thinking about buying a
car you're thinking about buying an X
you start seeing it on the street more
often why that's your reticular
activating system basically saying I
want to pay attention to those things so
that car was still around right I mean I
I got this car we've got a Porsche and
now I see Porsches more often those
Porsches still existed they were they
were already there I just didn't notice
them before and now I notice them
because I have one right
um so whatever it is that you want
whatever it is that you're setting
attention toward it's not just sit on
your couch and meditate and imagine
money coming into your wallet or a new
car or new house or business growth or
you speaking on stage or whatever your
goals are right it's not just
sitting on it and visualizing it but
it's noticing it and the elements of it
in your environment that when you start
thinking about it right we are we we
consistently think about when you start
thinking about it you'll start seeing
opportunities around you that were
already there
you just filtered it out because you
didn't see how it connected
now your brain's starting to make those
connections does that make sense
reticular activating system you're
ignoring most things
but when you set intention on the thing
that matters to you you'll start seeing
it in your environment and opportunities
for that to happen a lot more often so
that's step number one reticular
activating system it's the science
number two is to trust your intuition
more one of the things that really
helped me back early on in my career was
I
judge myself too harshly for the ideas
that I came up with
and as soon as I came up with an idea I
was like oh you can't do that or I had
to have the perfect Plan before I would
ever take any kind of action on it and
you know just later realize that you can
never plan all the way out there's no
way you know if you wait to have the
perfect plan by the time you start
actually executing the plan is is dead
it's over
um and so you have to trust in your
ideas and so the thing that really
helped me is
I believe the great ideas flow through
me believe the great ideas flow through
you this is how you shortcut them your
brain that's designed to keep you safe
that's how you show cut the brain out of
the equation
you came up with an idea as long as it's
in you're in a positive state of mind
you're trying to serve right it's not I
want to I want to go you're you're in a
jealous Rage or you're angry don't trust
your ideas then
but when when you're positive and
optimistic and bold and courageous and
an idea comes to you trust that that's
the right idea for you just trust it
it's already and then go do something
about it where normally what we do is we
overthink and we over plan we over
prepare and then we lose the momentum
and then the next day and the next week
or the next month it's gone it's over
it's like oh I can't do that no that was
actually a great idea for you and it's
happened enough to me
uh where those things have worked out
where I come up with an idea
and it doesn't make any sense
logically but I just decide to listen to
it and do something on it and it leads
to something amazing
the amount of times it has happened
is
pretty overwhelming
and so when you have enough repetition
for me I had to see it you know I had to
see it enough times come up because I
wouldn't just believe it on faith I had
to see it happen enough times and you
could test it yourself what ideas in
your head what big idea that you want to
do even a small idea what's what's
flowing through your head when you're in
a positive State you know put on a happy
song move around a little bit and then
notice your thoughts and where it's
going and what you want to create or who
you want to reach out to what you want
to do like what what thought comes to
mind after you're moving around and
having some positive energy that's
probably the right thing for you and
just test it out by doing something
about it and maybe that's a business
idea maybe that's an email you need to
send maybe that's a friend you need to
reach out to maybe that's an act of
kindness that you need to do whatever
the thing is that pops into your mind
trust those ideas and and you could be a
scientist like I'm I like data and I
like science and I like just I like
proving things
maybe I'm a skeptic I don't know but in
running those experiments I I proved to
myself that yeah great ideas do flow
through me
and so the next time I have a great idea
I'm gonna go and take action on it
so number one reticular activating
system
it's already in your environment you're
just ignoring it but if you put
attention towards you start seeing it
like you notice a new car when you buy
your new car you see that car everywhere
and then number two is trust a good
ideas flow through you
number three is the one that I'm working
on that I'm I'm having the hardest time
with and I I believe it and I'm trying
to I'm in the process of getting better
at it is
when you're thinking about creating
something to talk to yourself in the
present moment
and this is something that a lot of the
manifestation a lot of Attraction people
talk about but also
people like Grant Cardone talk about it
uh that is it's not just
the people who would associate with it
but other people have had a lot of
success where you're talking about
whatever thing is that you want that
it's that it's already happened that
it's not going to happen in the future
but that it's already happened you know
if your goal is to speak on stage then
you're visualizing and you're telling
yourself I I am I am on stage I am
speaking to
I am speaking to a million people or
that's that's a giant Stadium
I am speaking uh 70 000 people you know
I am I am the author of a best-selling
book uh I am like whatever your goal is
and what I think the point of that is is
yes one to see yourself accomplishing
big things uh two to not have a be so
far away that it lets you off the hook
for taking action but I think most
importantly is for you to feel what it
feels like to be that and the more you
feel like it feels like to be that the
more it actually becomes true if your
goal is to speak on stage in front of 5
000 people
and you actually
feel like you're doing it you can
visualize yourself being on stage and
doing it
the goal I think I'm still working
through this so one and two I've got
down three is my progress and my journey
so sharing with you
if you feel like you're doing it
if you are on stage and there's 5 000
people clapping for you and cheering you
you just gave the best speech you know
of your life so far
and you feel what it feels like to walk
off that stage and
what a gift that you gave people
that the more comfortable you get with
that feeling
the more it's going to be you
and the more that's going to show up
does that make sense so whatever it is
that you are trying to accomplish
whoever it is that you're trying to be
whatever your big goals are
that you imagine yourself already having
done it
and this is probably not something that
I would tell other people you know like
oh yeah I'm a I'm a you know I'm a
speaker in front of 70 000 people
[Music]
big
but
to yourself at least
to say it to see it to feel it to do it
if you're trying to heal yourself like
okay I am I am healthy
but look I've got I've got a belly or
I've got a you know whatever I'm I'm I
am healthy I am healthy and and
visualizing yourself being healthy
because you want the feeling of what it
feels like to be healthy and the more
you feel like you are healthy and you
capture that feeling the more frequently
you're in there the more likely it's
going to show up
so that's probably not the most
articulate way to share it and I'm still
working my way through it as well so as
I keep getting better and keep learning
I'll keep sharing with you but
I used to think like manifestation law
of attraction was way out there stuff
that that I judged and that I didn't
understand and that didn't make any
sense like just go off and take action
guys and
with time and experience and exposure
and practice
um using the reticular activating system
to notice things around me by trusting
that great ideas flow through me and
following through and building momentum
and by talking to myself in the present
moment as if I am that person that I
want to become so I can capture that
feeling and know what it feels like to
be that person
I've shifted and seen some pretty
amazing results in my life in business
and I hope it can work for you too
number two defeat all your fear
I think the key to over
fear is the awareness of the fear I
think most people aren't even a aware of
their biggest fears that are holding
them back on a daily basis in their
business and in their lives what often
happens is somebody gives you an
opportunity right come speak at this
event or here's this project and work
with this person or go on this date
whatever it is you get an opportunity
and the real fear you have is that
you're not good enough that you're gonna
fail that you're not gonna give a good
result that's really the fear deep down
inside but you come up with I don't have
the time to do it I don't have the time
to do it as the biggest BS excuse of all
time you may not be making the priority
to go out and do it but we all have the
same amount of time you you should never
say I don't have the time you can say I
choose not to do it I choose not to make
the time but as soon as you say I don't
have the time you abdicate
responsibility you are in control you
get to pick what you do with your 24
hours every day it's the one thing that
is equal across every human being we all
have 24 hours so we disguise our real
fear with some practical reason right we
say we don't have the time we don't have
the resources blah blah blah whatever it
is but really it's some kind of fear and
I think I think that's the case for a
lot of people so many of our fears are
so subconscious and we're so we do it so
automatically every single day and we've
convinced ourselves that there's a
logical reason behind it so the first
step in my mind is the awareness of the
fear the awareness that it's not a lack
of resources the awareness has not a
lack of time
and it's really that I'm just afraid
that I'm gonna fail and I don't want to
do it anymore so awareness of the fear
is the first thing next thing is do you
have a why to get out of it is it
important to break that thing is it
important to crush through that fear do
you have a strong enough reason to make
a painful change and when you do the
third step is to start to catch it
and you often can't catch it in the
moment usually comes afterwards usually
you're meeting with somebody and you do
the same thing that you always do and
you don't catch it in the moment you
catch it the next day the guy did it
again I did it I should have said that I
should have done that and I did and I
did it again
succumb to my fear again and when you
have that awareness what you'll find is
the awareness starts getting closer and
closer and closer and closer to the
moment where it's actually happening
so you started off and it's like the
next day when you realize it and then
next time it's maybe a couple hours
later next time is a couple minutes
later and then you get to that magical
moment that magical moment where you've
caught yourself just before you take the
action
you're meeting with somebody and they're
giving you a project and you're about to
back away the words are about to come
out of your mouth it's about to happen
again the same pattern that you've
always done forever and ever is about to
come out again and you have that magical
moment to catch yourself
and choose to be bold to overcome the
fear to push through it and take a
separate action instead of going the
same path you always go
swerve and go this way and when you do
that it gives you the muscle to do it
again and every time you get to that
point it's going to become easier and
easier and easier and easier and easier
so one for me is understand what your
real fear is I think we have the
awareness to have a strong enough why to
get out of it and then three get closer
and closer and closer to the moment
where it's happening and then choose to
be bold choose to be powerful and choose
to push through your fear rule number
three be willing to change you're not
changing because you're trying to do
everything yourself you're trying to do
it all alone you can have a moment of
inspiration moment of this is the day
I'm gonna change it all and then when
your environment and people around you
don't support you in doing it and you're
doing it all alone you lose momentum the
next day that momentum is gone and the
next day the momentum is is absolutely
zero have you ever you ever been there
until you get the people around you to
support you to create a circle where
where you can feel like you do not have
to do this alone
you won't change
and you'll stay stuck knowing that
you're capable of more
and frustrated with yourself with the
lack of momentum I run this challenge
inside my movement makers program and
every month we have to talk about a
certain topic movement makers is For
Thought leaders it's people who are they
have a message they have a mission they
want to get out to the world your story
matters let's get it out there and go
come on
but it's really hard to share your story
and it's really hard to make videos and
it's really hard to put yourself out
there and you have these moments where
you want to do it and you feel on top of
the world like yes I'm ready and then
and then what then all the insecurities
and fears and doubts creep in and
as I was noticing people and Movie
Makers not making enough content I
decided to do a challenge and the
challenge is once a month we pick a
topic
and this month's topic is courage
and what you have to do is make a solo
video that's 10 minutes long you have to
make a lead magnet to help grow your
business and you have to do three
collaboration videos and most people do
Instagram lives they collaborate with
each other and all of a sudden
people who took up the challenge started
making content all of a sudden the
excuses went away the I don't know what
gear to buy I don't know what camera to
use I don't know what microphone I don't
know what to talk about my story is not
good enough I'll start next week I'll
start next year I'll start next month
I'll start on my birthday I'll start on
January 1st I'll start on Monday I'll
start I'll start next month right all of
the all of the excuses all of a sudden
went away
because you're not doing it alone
because all of those reasons that are
holding people back that are holding you
back you want to do something bigger
all of the reasons that are actually
holding you back are not The Logical
ones that are in your head
right the idea that you're not making
content because you don't know what
phone to use or what camera to use or
what I'm sit I'm making these videos for
my channel on my phone I'm I'm in my car
at my wife's acupuncturist she's getting
acupuncture done right now in the
building right next to me and so I'm
making content in my car you can too
right there are logical reasons why you
are not doing a thing that you want to
do right that you say is important to
you there's logical reasons that you are
buying
you you've you've you believe them they
are actual reasons but they're not good
enough reasons and underneath those
reasons why you're not doing the thing
that you need to do is just that you're
afraid
it's just fear
and suffering through fear alone
is really really hard it's not that it's
not possible it's not that you can't do
it it's just immensely difficult and
most people won't most people won't
follow through most people don't follow
through because they are alone
in this journey you might have people
around you you might you might have
great parents friends a spouse
but if you feel like you're walking the
journey all by yourself
it's just insanely difficult to actually
follow through and get the results that
you want
the good news is you can change it right
the good news is hey we don't have to
stay stuck the good news is you can
Circle and I'm gonna share a couple
ideas in this video of how to do it so
number one
I like to collect good people
collect good people
around you in your life how many of them
make you feel happier more energetic
more positive and you may not have many
people you know there you may not have
someone like that
great
think about the people who you've ever
met
maybe it was at a conference maybe an
event maybe a lunch or dinner some kind
of party a friend of a friend
I
find ways to spend more time with good
people I remind myself that I like to
collect good people and as someone who's
shy and introverted
that's that's
not my default state
I don't think to call people I don't
think the message people I don't I don't
default to being around people but when
there's somebody who's energy I really
love and I leave the conversation
feeling more uplifted than when I went
in
then I I try to find ways to spend more
time with that person and maybe it leads
to a business maybe it leads to some
kind of opportunity maybe just leads to
another conversation but think about the
people who you have met at some point in
your life maybe not the people around
you right now but an old high school
friend or again somebody at an event or
a club or some meeting that you met that
you really like their energy and their
Vibe I'll lean in on the awkward and say
hey do you want to go grab a coffee I'd
love to learn more about your story or I
really love your energy
do you want to go and get some lunch
together
you it feels super awkward but chances
are they need somebody too
and if you be the first one to do the
Outreach and say hey I'd love to learn
more about you see the people who you
don't really know that well but you'd
like to
and you can even say that when you're
talking to them hey I don't really know
you that well but I'd like to
and lean in on the awkwardness be the
first one to go off and do it so so
think about the people in your network
people who you have met one-off meetings
who filled you with that positivity and
and fight for more time with them
because if you had four people
and you met everybody once a month
that's once a week now you're meeting
some amazing human
whether it's coffee whether it's lunch
whether it's a zoom call whether it's
actually forming some kind of business
together there are people who you've
come across who
are the support that you need and you
need to do the Outreach to say hey I'd
like to get to know you a little bit
better and spend a little more time with
you
leaning on the awkwardness collect good
people that's number one two is is
change your environment to be around the
people even if you can't meet them so
watching this video is a great example
watch this video did you wake up this
morning you're like yeah my gosh so
amazing let's go Crush today
[Laughter]
probably not right I didn't if you if if
you did then I am super jealous of you
if I woke up and you're tired and you
look at your phone and what's on my
calendar for today and immediately some
of the limiting beliefs and thoughts and
attitudes uh popped in your head and so
if you can't be around the people every
day you know the collective people if
you can't be around them every day then
you can be around them virtually
through video through YouTube through
books through uh social media follow the
people who make you feel better about
yourself and make you want to go off and
Conquer your goals
most of the time when people are
spending time on social media YouTube
Instagram Etc
how much of that time is spent actually
learning and being inspired versus
wasting time
how many times have you opened your
phone went to a social media app and all
of a sudden 40 minutes went by you
didn't even notice because you're just
scrolling scrolling scrolling scrolling
right has that happened
that's that's that's not what you want
to do
don't lean in on that right audit right
now audit who you are subscribed to on
YouTube and who you're following on
Instagram and ask yourself do these
people make me feel better about myself
or not
do I leave feeling more inspired than
when I came in and if no then unfollow
those people and good news is lots of
amazing people not just me there's tons
of amazing people who are making amazing
content
and whatever you want to learn whatever
you want to get more into
when you can surround yourself even in a
social media environment if you wanted
to work out more if you followed a whole
bunch of Fitness people people who are
working out constantly people who are
not you're making excuses for why they
can't get to the gym today if you
followed all those people it's now in
your environment you'll start to see it
more often it'll become it'll become
that daily reminder for you and you're
more likely to go to the gym and work
out so whatever you want to be whoever
you want to be whatever your goals are
choose to follow the people who are
achieving those goals who are living
that because it's not your identity yet
and for them it is and the more you're
around that they will suck you in to be
like them so choose very carefully what
you want to get sucked into right it can
also lead down a really negative dark
path right whoever's more confident in
their beliefs win so if you're around
people who are strongly believing in
something that is that is bad or evil or
you know against your core values you
know you could be sucked down a really
dark negative hole as well so Step One
is collect good people step two is to be
around them be around in social media
with intention the people who make you
feel better about yourself and and go
achieve your goals and then step three
is to join some kind of community join
some kind of group uh who are focused in
on on what you're trying to do so if you
wanna
if you want to get into fitness then you
you can hire a coach to help your
fitness trainer or join a gym or join
some kind of collective where you feel
like you don't have to do this by
yourself why movement makers is so
special is because if you want to be a
thought leader where do you go where do
you go to hang out with other thought
leaders
right nowhere do you know anybody who's
a thought leader is trying to make great
content and share it and have a message
to give to the world you know who who
else that you know in your life talks
like that probably not right so being
around that and and whatever it is that
you want to learn you want to be better
at chess then join a chess club and hire
a chess coach be around the people
be around the people join some kind of
community so you don't have to do this
all alone one of the things that I
struggled the most with is feeling like
I have to come up with all the ideas
myself carrying everything on my back
and what I realized
varied later in my entrepreneurial
Journey right I mean I'm I'm
what I'm 40 how old am I now 40 I'm
almost 42 when I'm filming this video my
first Real Business and Entrepreneurship
when I was 19 so it's been a while you
know 20 plus years of being an
entrepreneur
uh not including like garage sales and
that kind of stuff and one of the
hardest things for me was just not
trying to have to do everything myself
not putting all the pressure on myself
to have to do everything everything
everything all by myself
I like to say movement makers that one
plus one equals four thousand you know
like you come in
and not just movement makers but any
anytime you do this any any club you
join or group you join especially if
you're a giver givers have a hard time
asking but when you're with other givers
they want to pour into you they want to
give to you they want to see you win as
well so you come in hoping to get
something and then when you get that
plus you can contribute to other people
and what they're doing and see that
you're showing up for them also allows
them to go off and accomplish their
goals
it's just such a great cycle
and it's such a weight lifted to know
that you don't have to do everything all
by yourself
so you could be willing to change you
could have these great Ambitions and
great ideas of who you could be and who
you want to be and the impact that you
want to have
but it's not going to happen until you
realize that you can't do this alone
stop trying to do this alone stop trying
to do everything yourself
you can change people will support you
but it's on you to collect good people
to audit who you follow on social media
and
and to join a group of people who are
like-minded
if you want to make one single change
this year
that will have a tremendous impact on
the growth of you actually accomplishing
your goals
decide to not do this alone anymore rule
number four transform your thinking you
don't have to stay stuck
when you come up with a great idea that
in your heart you know this is the thing
that I want to do and then almost
instantly all the negative voices come
in your head as to why you can't do it
and why someone like you will never be
able to do this thing
keeps you stuck keeps you small keeps
you frustrated keeps you knowing that
you're capable of more and being too
afraid to go take the action and until
you can break that pattern of negative
self-talk
nothing will happen
and so we're gonna fix that in this
video I think as soon as we come up with
ideas
it's not even our friends it's not even
the people around us it's us it's us
telling ourselves that we suck that we
can't do it that we're not good enough
that we're not capable that it's not
gonna happen
we'd land into
procrastination mode and you can call
yourself a perfectionist it has to be
perfect
but perfectionism is still just fear
just fear just fear that you're not good
enough feel that it won't work out fear
of being seen fear of not being seen and
it keeps you stuck
when I procrastinate on things even like
making videos
yeah I've made I don't know how many
twelve thousand thirteen thousand
fourteen thousand videos some crazy
number of videos and yet every time
before I sit down to make the videos I
procrastinate a little bit
in today's filming session I'm here at
my wife's Acupuncture Clinic she's
inside getting her acupuncture done I
joined her sitting in the car and it
probably took me
15 minutes
to get into
The Zone I know I'm gonna make the
videos I've developed the identity that
I'm gonna get get it done but I'm I'm
worried I want I want the videos to be
good I wanted I don't want to embarrass
myself don't want to let myself down
don't want to let you down if you're
disappointing people is my my biggest
fear I don't want you to feel like this
is wasting your time you ever had these
thoughts you know like you want to do
something and then you want it to be
good and you don't want to disappoint
people and so you him and you ha and you
procrastinate and then and then all of a
sudden the day is gone you haven't done
anything you know has that happened so I
try to keep it to 10 minutes 15 minutes
it is a little longer I'd usually be
like five ten minutes it took a little
bit longer 15 minutes today to get into
to get into the zone and you know what
happened the next thought was
but what if I just check uh check and
see how my team is doing and and
because I want to feel valuable and
because I want to feel like I'm doing
something productive I want to get out
of the discomfort of not filming videos
and go check in on my team because that
would make me feel more productive like
no no no no
sit with it
we gotta we gotta change it we gotta go
we gotta make some content you're gonna
do this and make that first video so
even for me even for someone who's done
five figures of videos
every time I sit in front of the camera
to make a video the first one I
procrastinate I sit on it because I'm
afraid
and I don't want to disappoint people so
it's totally normal so if you feel like
whatever the thing is that you want to
do
you know you're capable of it you know
in your heart that it's something that
you want to create and then for some
reason you keep stopping you keep
procrastinating you keep staying stuck
that's normal you're not there's nothing
wrong with you it's not abnormal it's
100 everybody goes through it the
difference is how quickly can you shift
how can you get unstuck
because most people just stay stuck they
stay constipated
like all this all the stuff that has to
come out that's just coming out
you're constipated
so how do you do it how do you shift it
here are a couple things that helped me
that I hope can help you number one is
is floss the first tooth take immediate
momentum you think about flossing
people don't want to floss I mean my
floss I've built the habit of flossing
twice a day most people don't floss and
the concept is just floss one tooth and
once you've floss one tooth you'll floss
the rats probably right just get your
running shoes on and go for a walk and
once you're walking you'll probably do
more than you know the two minutes that
you set yourself into mine like just do
two minutes so for me is just make the
first video
come on Evan just record the first video
so I recorded the first video and now
this is my second video in my filming
session and I'm already feeling better
it's like we're going we're vibing yeah
let's do this is amazing
come on
just get going just just go it's so much
easier to keep the momentum going once
you've built some momentum the hardest
step is the first step the hardest step
is just building that initial momentum
at the beginning once you get going it's
a lot easier to keep going so just start
don't don't make it some big thing
they'll make it some giant Endeavor that
you have to go off and Chase it's nice
to have big goals and big Ambitions and
Big Dreams but sometimes they're too big
and then you feel like you can't do it
and you need venture capital and you
need a team and you need all sorts of
things before you can do anything on it
it's great to have that big goal and
what are you gonna do today
to build some kind of momentum
and once you start building up momentum
it's just so much so much so much so
much easier so the challenge for today
is just just find one small simple easy
way to get started it doesn't have to be
amazing it doesn't have to be great it's
just the first step once you get your
first step it's so much easier to take
the second so that's why just start
building some immediate momentum number
two is change your state
one of the reasons why I like filming in
the car people ask why are you always
filming in your car I like I like being
out I like I like being out of the place
out of my home I like I like energy I
like nature I like being able to see
trees and and sunshine and have people
around you know I like I like that it
changes my state it's it makes it a lot
easier for me to go off and film when
I'm by myself so it's not just
um me talking to the camera if this
feels more conversational I don't know
it's all it's all just a a head game
but it feels more it feels like I'm
talking to a friend hello how you doing
I'm Evan it feels it feels more
conversational and natural for me I like
having the sun on my face you know it
just feels better and so changing your
state can be a good way if you're in a
wherever you're at you know think
whether you're in your bed or in your
car or in your office or the dining room
table you know change your state move
around get up
you want to change the negative thoughts
start moving get up doesn't have to go
work out or do you know 100 jumping
jacks just get up and even get in some
fresh air getting out of the space that
you're thinking negatively in really
helps just changing your physical
location really really really really
helps I promise you have you ever had a
uh you're thinking really negatively
um you're procrastinating you're feeling
down and then you go for a walk and you
feel better or even just change your
room or you go to a different part of
the house or you go for a drive and then
you feel better like changing the
physical environment can really help you
get out of that funk that you're in
where while you're in that space you're
feeling
stuck and you can't move so change your
physical environment one little bonus to
that is music music I should have done
that today music is
the fastest way to change your state so
while I was sitting here in the car for
15 minutes procrastinating making these
videos instead of thinking hey I should
go and check in on my team and see how
they're doing underneath like logically
that makes sense like how's my team
doing I'm being a good boss you know
good manager a good friend I should
check in on them see how they're doing
it's going to move my goals forward of
course because if they're waiting on me
for something right logically all that
makes sense underneath it is just again
the fear that my videos won't be good
enough so I need to feel productive I
need to feel value valuable to myself I
need to feel worthy so I'm going to
spend my time there instead of making
videos right I should have put on music
when that was happening
instead of going to check out my team
which I didn't do but wanted to
uh I should have put on some music
put on some music that makes you move
and you don't have to be the most
expressive dancer or singer just
anything that would get your head bobbin
or your foot tapping or your knee
bouncing just songs that make you come
alive and there's no one Perfect song
but whatever song gets you in the zone
even if you're feeling really low you'll
find yourself like having energy and
moving and it changes your state the
whole point is just to get on stock and
to start building some momentum towards
what you say is what you want to do
right so music is a fast way to change
your state and then number three is I
would say have play bigger triggers
and play bigger triggers are the things
in your environment that remind you of
who you want to be
things that you could put up the the
reminders on your cell phone background
on your desktop background the artwork
on your wall the things that you could
put in your life to remind you of who
you want to be so I'll share a couple
from my example in my office I have five
pictures on the wall and they all tell a
different story remind me of who I want
to be I've got Steve Jobs on the wall
who reminds me to be a Visionary I've
got epginini on the wall who's my
favorite entrepreneur of all time and he
reminds me to to believe in
um in the little guy and what I'm trying
to do I've got my parents on the wall
who remind me to believe in myself I've
got Howard Schultz on the wall who
reminds me to stand for something
important they've got Kanye on the wall
to remind me that the time is now that I
have to go do something now to be the
greatest Meme and
those pictures I picked with intention
and when I walk into my office they're
there and they remind me and I don't
have to do anything you know you set it
up once and it reminds me it reminds you
of who you want to be I walk in the
office there's my parents looking back
at me and telling me to believe in
myself the clothes that you wear right I
wear I wear this is my believe hoodie I
feel like I'm Batman I tell myself when
I put this on I'm Batman I'm a superhero
going to work fighting
the crime of lack of belief
somebody commented on my hoodie
yesterday's like you're always wearing
you're always on brand you're always
wearing your hoodie it's like it's not
just it's not just when I show up to
make videos this is this is this is what
I wear because I'm a I'm a superhero
going to work and when I put this on in
the morning it's like I'm I'm Batman
going to work or uh uh you know police
officer going to work it's like this is
this is what I do
and
I'm a lot more
for me
productive and ambitious and bold when
I'm wearing this compared to when I'm in
my pajamas
and so there's a conscious choice to say
okay what do I want to wear and so the
artwork on my wall the background on my
cell phone the computer screen
background the the things that I wear
right play bigger triggers
that you've ideally just set it up once
and then it reminds you it's okay there
it is there's my trigger again there
there it is that this is who I want to
be this is who I want to be this is who
I want to be I'm around the things that
make me remember what I'm trying to do
because your brain will trick you to
stay small your brain will trick you to
stay stuck your brain will trick you to
say
yeah you you can't do that and here's
all the reasons why
and you believe those reasons you
believe those reasons who are really
you're just afraid I'm just afraid I'm
afraid that we're not good enough we're
afraid that we're going to be judged
we're afraid of disappointed people
we're afraid of not being loved we're
afraid that
we're going to be seen and gonna be made
fun of you know we're just afraid at the
end of the day you me everybody we're
just we're just afraid that the reason
why you're stuck is you're afraid and so
when you can learn to catch those
feelings
and when you can learn to uncover those
feelings and switch them say you know
what
I'm going to change my environment I'm
going to change my state I'm going to
change what I'm listening to I'm going
to change what I'm wearing I'm going to
change my mind and I'm going to go do
the thing to start building momentum
because the only thing you're missing is
momentum the only thing you're missing
is momentum you've got a great heart a
great Soul a great idea your idea is
worthy you're doing it for the right
reasons you want to serve you can do
this you can be in a totally different
place in six months and 12 months you
can it's possible you can your mission
is worthy and Noble and should happen
and you're the one to do it you you're
the one to do it
and it's not that you're not good enough
and it's not that you're not capable and
it's not that you can't do it at some
point you just don't have the momentum
momentum
dismissing momentum
and so the next time you feel stuck
procrastinating not good enough
know that you can do it
and that all you need to do is take that
first step also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet design
specifically for this video absolutely
for free there's a link in the
description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
rule number five improve your
productivity my key to being productive
is doing
different activities different energy
states on different days if you feel
like you're getting to the end of the
day you're getting to the end of the
week and you're working like crazy like
you're working you you were not sucking
off you're working like crazy and yet
nothing seemed to happen because have
you gotten there it's like I did so much
work this week and yet I've moved very
little towards actually accomplishing my
goals if that's you
the way to change it is to realize that
you're flipping between energy states
too much and you're not you're not
tapping into your true productivity so
let me share with you what I do and
hopefully that gives you some value to
planning your schedule in your life as
well
different tasks on different days I'll
break down for you what I do every day
of the week
Monday is my mentoring day Mondays are
the days where I spend mentoring my team
and we've got 37 people on my team
there's a bunch of people who I've
invested into as well in their companies
and Monday I just spend the whole day
talking to them all I have to worry
about is mentoring the people on my team
Tuesday is YouTube day so today I'm
filming on a Tuesday I don't know what
day this video is being released but
it's a Tuesday for me filming all I have
to worry about on a Tuesday is making
YouTube content and why it's so
productive these days is because it
takes a while to make the first video it
takes a while to do the first call takes
a while to get momentum going but once
you get the momentum going
it's easier to stay in the momentum than
if you switch to something else it takes
a lot longer to get into that momentum
so quick example it's YouTube day for me
it took me 15 minutes to get ready for
the first video and not get ready like I
have to do my hair
get ready just emotionally get ready
mentally get get ready not procrastinate
get ready to bring the energy and have
the right Vibe and feel good enough and
and all of the stuff it takes took me 15
minutes to get ready and then the first
video
it takes it takes a while to get the
Mojo going and then after the first
video the second one is better and the
third one is better this is my fourth
one recording is better and now it's
easier to go right and so in the time it
takes me to make one video the first
video I could then in that same amount
of time go make three or four videos
intermediate intermediate I want to say
sequential that's not a word succession
succession intermediate succession
whatever
after I can make three or four more
videos right after while I'm in that
same Vibe so same thing for you whatever
Vibe you're feeling if you can stay in
that energy Zone instead of switching if
I did YouTube video then write in a book
then doing a phone call that meant for
my team then you're just bouncing around
too much in this high high high energy
switching costs that then keep you
unproductive then this is I mean a huge
unlock because when you can figure out
how to chunk your time like this
brain fog goes away productivity
dramatically increases you suddenly have
a lot more free time as well to do
whatever you want to do Nina is back
she's in the house we are at Nina's
acupuncture let me put my seatbelt on as
we well as we get ready to go
so Tuesday's YouTube day and I spend the
whole day making videos Wednesday is
Project day and on Project day I focus
on whatever projects I want to work on
and it's
I wake up in the morning I look at what
do I want to work on today and it's a
it's a lot more of a creative day
Tuesdays and Thursdays are very intense
productive days Wednesday is a
free-flowing day which is not very
productive but very creative what I had
to understand is creativity is messy and
creativity is not productive so I would
judge myself harshly when I was working
on a new project and it would take me a
long time and I felt like I got nothing
done that's okay like creativity is not
meant to be efficient
but you won't be efficient on your
creative days or in your creative tasks
it won't be efficient for you but that's
okay and I think you need to have
creative time built into your calendar
because if you're only doing things that
are productive you're going to burn out
you're going to hit your life and you're
gonna feel Limited you ever get bored of
your own business you get bored of the
things you're doing well there's not
enough creative time planned into your
week when do you get time to work on new
fun things that maybe pay off maybe
don't pay off when you have time to work
on that well you don't okay so that's
when people have midlife crisis or
burnout or want to throw it all away or
quit or stop doing this thing and so I
think you have to have some highly
productive days where you're really
working on achieving the goals that you
know I have to get these things done and
then you have to have some creative days
where you get to focus on whatever
projects you want that you're not
judging yourself harshly for being you
know not very efficient creativity is
messy it's designed to be that way and
you need to have some creative days in
your calendar or you will get tired of
your business and hate your life so
that's Wednesday Wednesday is creative
Day project day Thursday is public
facing day and Thursdays
I'm usually starting the day with either
movement makers or brand lytics and I'm
I'm introverted and shy and that doesn't
come across in these videos but I am and
it takes me a while to to get into the
zone of being around other people
[Laughter]
so I'm
on start with my family and movement
makers are my community of thought
leaders are trying to build their
business and get their message to the
world and Brent Linux is my community of
people on YouTube who want to build
their YouTube channel up specifically
and want the advice to to grow and
create and so I start my Thursdays with
them because it's it's family it's safe
it's friendly it's warm and it makes me
feel like what I do matters and is
important and then the rest of Thursday
is interviews and podcasts and and zoom
calls and just all day spreading the
message
spreading the message you know we got we
got believed to put out there and it's
easy to go off and do those things now
because I just came from movement makers
or brand Linux so I'm already in the in
the zone of sharing and creating and
impacting and seeing smiles and so I
carry that energy into my next interview
on my next podcast and the next thing
that I'm doing so if I'm booking to be
on other people's shows even if I'm
booking for my own show Thursdays it's
always on a Thursday it's always on a
Thursday it's always on a Thursday and I
have five minute breaks in between so
it's usually 25 minutes or 55 minutes
and then five minute break and then on
to the next one on to the next one and
so it's really easy and all of a sudden
it's seven o'clock and
what happened to today I don't know but
amazing things happened because you're
all in that energy and you know do tons
of different shows and episodes and
again so much easier to be in that in
that one zone than to then go make a
YouTube video or then go and wrap my
book or then you know book writing was a
creative project so it's on a Wednesday
it took me an hour just to get into
remembering what I did yesterday or last
week on my book right so if you only
give yourself an hour to write the book
that would be absolute waste of time
because it took me an hour to remember
where I left off last time
uh since there's a public-facing day
Friday is CEO day so that's what do we
need to do to grow my business you know
what what are the big projects instead
of working in my business work on the
business so Wednesday's work in the
business on Creative projects Friday is
if I'm going to be the CEO of my
business what does that look like what
do I need to be doing because if you're
an entrepreneur you're you're the CEO
you're probably the janitor as well if
you're a one-person show and we have to
do a lot of things to drive the business
forward we have to be in our business we
don't have a giant team yet even at 37
people I do a lot of work in the
business as opposed to only just being
the CEO and just managing and
truthfully I like being in the business
I like like making videos like this is
not CEO time this is me being in the
business but I like it you know I think
I think people who often just be the CEO
if you're entrepreneurial and there's no
projects you're working on uh you you
grow distant from the business you don't
enjoy it so we all need time in our
calendar every week to focus on being
the CEO and now I spend all my Fridays
doing it at the beginning I just started
with two hours so two hours in my
calendar okay this is my CEO time and I
blocked it off and it made it important
and when I started doing that I started
seeing more results in my company
Saturday we applied to the weekends too
Saturday is fun day so Saturday spending
time with Nina doing whatever you know
going and starting to get warm here in
Canada
you can see you know the grass finally
green so if we're going for a hike or
trying out a restaurant or going to a
street festival or just something fun
Sunday is family at midday so all of the
stuff that we have to do to manage the
family you know go grocery shopping fold
laundry clean up the house
family admin kind of stuff that's on a
Sunday and then repeat the next day so
again quick summary Monday is mentoring
day Tuesday is YouTube day Wednesday's
project day Thursday is public facing
day Friday CEO day Saturday fun day and
Sunday is family admin day and that fits
my life
you know that's a calendar for my life
it won't photocopy perfectly over to
yours but the key is to chunk your time
and think about what is a balanced life
look like for me so that I'm happy I'm
creative I'm productive I'm moving
closer to becoming the person that I
want to be and if you can't control
your calendar fully maybe you have a job
maybe you have other responsibilities
maybe you're still stuck doing some
things you don't want to do that's cool
don't don't stress out and worry about
oh I can't I can't completely control my
day I can't have a YouTube day okay
don't worry about it you have some
controllable time focus on the control
of the time you have and just be more
intentional with it
so that you're not wasting time
scrolling through Instagram posts or
YouTube videos mindlessly that that
you're you're there with intention and
you're gonna you have so many you have a
certain amount of controllable hours I
think part of the advantage of being an
entrepreneur is we have a lot more
controllable hours right if you're a
full-time entrepreneur you get the
control sure we have to you know be uh
be responsive to our customers but we
don't have a boss
and we get to choose when we show up and
we get to choose what our calendar looks
like and that's part of the Allure being
an entrepreneur is that freedom but if
you're not completely there yet you
still have controllable hours when you
get home from work to the time you go to
bed when you wake up to the time you go
to work and then on weekends you have
controllable hours
be more intentional with them
and decide what is the life that you
want to live that'll come down to then
the habits that you're executing on
daily which comes down to your calendar
and when you can chunk similar tasks
together
when you can stay in the same energy
Zone instead of switching between a
mainly different tasks every day it
allows you to be more productive it
allows you to be more effective it
allows you to be happier and allows you
to get a lot closer to your goals rule
number six choose to show up with love
way to shoot to shift your mindset in a
positive direction is to choose to show
up with love if you're stressed out if
you're fearful if you've got anxiety if
you're low on energy just shift just
tell yourself I'm gonna show up with
love and see how that moves you forward
in a positive direction otherwise you
get stuck you stay stuck because you
listen to the voices in your hand as to
you're not good enough why you can't do
it and everybody's doing better than you
and and so on where when you can choose
a show with love it just negates all of
that so let me share a couple examples
that I've used it in my life and
hopefully it applies to your life as
well to help you get the momentum that
you need so scenario number one is when
you're stressed out when you are
overwhelmed when you're doing something
scary or you're in doubt and you come up
with all these reasons why you can't do
something so for me it's staying on
stage you know going on stage doing a
big presentation even making these
videos every time before doing something
that I want to be good
that I'm worried about that I might
disappoint somebody the procrastination
sets in the fearful thoughts set in
because I wanted to be the best that
I've ever done
my biggest fear is still disappointing
people and instead of listening to those
thoughts and how it may show up is oh
um my message isn't good enough oh I
don't know what gear to use maybe not in
my case for that one but what prevents
you from doing it there's logical
reasons but really just fear talking
where if you can
decide you know if I'm making this video
is it my best video of all time maybe I
want it to be is it likely not but I'm
trying and
the way Thrillers should show up with
love like I love you I love you thank
you for being here thank you for
investing in yourself thank you for
putting putting goodness out into the
world you know I make these videos
because you can reach people that I
can't your business your heart your soul
your your beliefs what you've been
through your story can touch people and
change the world in a way that I can't
and so if I can be a little bit of a
push motivation whatever to help you
start doing something that makes me
happy it fills me up knowing that that
what I'm doing matters is important
right so show but love that's all I have
to do don't worry about it being the
best for you of all time just show up
with love don't worry about it being the
best speech of all time just show up
with love remember why you're doing it
it's another version of it right like
why are you doing this thing but not
from an extra pressure you know if you
if you feel over pressured to be great
then that can be debilitating to the
point where you freeze a lot of
procrastinations you're just afraid to
do the thing and so choose to show up
with love I love this person I love who
I'm trying to help even if you don't
know them right some of you are watching
this video I've never met you before
thank you for being here
even if you say I love you even mentally
I love this person I love I love my eyes
I love my customers even if you haven't
met them yet it rewires you it just
makes it so much easier try it like what
are you procrastinating on that you want
to get done that you know you want to
get done not that that you don't want to
do but you want to do it's part of your
goals it's your Ambitions that you hope
one day you could be that person right
what are you procrastinate on and just
flip it from having to be perfect to
saying I love these people I'm gonna
show up with love and watch it just
shift you so you can actually start
taking some momentum it's a huge huge
huge huge huge thing for anything that
you're procrastinating on that you're
afraid of so scenario number one
uh the things that you're afraid of
scenario two is is people and
specifically the people who are who are
negative the haters that we might call
it I don't actually like the term haters
I don't I don't think there are haters I
think there's just people who are in a
lot of pain you know I think if somebody
is
highlight of their days to show up and
leave something negative on your website
on your YouTube video on your social
media accounts whatever they're in a lot
of pain you know I think people are
built to serve we are good we want to
help we want to we want to contribute
and so somebody that's everybody like
everybody wants to serve so if somebody
is showing up with negativity in their
heart thrown at you when they've never
even met you before
uh why would they do that well they're
in a lot of pain
hurt people hurt people
and so
a lot of times we get uh emotional you
know we don't like seeing those negative
comments I don't like seeing negative
comments even on a channel like mine
where it's only positivity I'm not
making bash videos on people
if somebody's gonna show up to a Channel
about positivity and leave negative
comments how how much in pain do they
need to be and to do that and even just
seeing it like that already starts to
shift it but what if you were to say I
love this person like how would you show
up if you love that if you loved your
hater
not because it fuels you to go prove
them wrong and be better but
feel bad for them not sorry for them but
just have empathy for them and say you
love them like if you love this person
how would you show up differently
instead of allowing that comment that
they left on your video to ruin your day
to make to maybe make you never post
again to get into a fight or debate or
respond uh to them you know and try to
win win the battle instead of that if
you actually said hey I love this person
even if you don't like you don't know
them you might think well that's
ridiculous I don't know this person I
get I know I understand this is not your
mom coming on your YouTube channel and
saying that you suck it's some random
stranger you've never met and maybe you
don't even know who they are and you
can't see their name in their profile
pictures of cartoon right or soccer
player uh so that's fine but even if you
just say I love this person how would it
change if you love this person and watch
it shift you watch the chemicals and you
start to shift towards you now being
more proud of yourself if you show up
with love it allows you to have the
courage to be the person who you want to
be who you're proud of like when you get
some negative comment and then you
respond in a really snarky way or you
show up somebody slights you some way
somebody cuts you off in traffic I'm in
my car right now somebody cuts you off
in traffic and you have to you have to
catch up to them and give them the look
or cut them off or Blast Your Horn you
know if you actually thought about that
are you ever proud of yourself
are you proud of yourself in those
moments like if you reflect back and say
see what you did in reaction are you
proud of how you showed up probably not
right probably not at least I'm not when
that happens and so the way through it
is is to show up with love like even
just tell yourself I love this person
I'll practice it with random people on
the streets you know like I'm walking
down the street and somebody comes by
and like I love this person just as a
mental exercise of practice how do you
show up instead of just being head down
ignoring them you know looking at your
phone maybe give them a smile it feels
really weird especially as an introvert
shy person
um I don't go up and say hi to people
but it's a good practice to get into but
especially for the haters like number
one and two one is again you're afraid
you're stuck you're overthinking
stressed out and number two is you're
you're also afraid but of people's
opinions and specifically the negativity
that's out there what they do is they
prevent you from taking action it keeps
you out of momentum
you're just stuck in fear Zone instead
of creation Zone and so
the opposite of fear is love
it's not hate like the opposite of Love
is in hate the opposite of Love is fear
and so it allows you to get out of the
fearful mindset and into a loving
mindset which is not just
fluffy it's not it's not
you know what I'm saying it gives you
into momentum mode moving from Fear To
Love allows you to take action and
that's what makes it super practical
so
have love even in your own mind for who
you're trying to serve and what you're
trying to create have love for any
negativity any people who are who are
criticizing you they're not haters
they're just people in a lot of pain and
show them love
and watch how it shifts you into
momentum and in the third scenario is
love and for yourself
you just need to love ourselves more so
the first two are loved that are
outwardly pointed right out toward our
customers or the audience towards people
who are disagreeing with us or
disrespecting us or hating hating on us
but the third one is just self-love more
self-compassion self-love love love that
you showed up today love that you
decided to watch this video today love
that you're you're fighting to chase
down your goals and your dreams even in
the face of not getting a lot of results
or not being where you want to be you
know you're you're probably not where
you want to be right now and maybe
you're not proud of the week that you've
had or the day that you've had or the
month that you had or the year that
you've had that you could have done
better you should be you should be
further ahead right you ever thought has
that ever popped into your mind
so self-love again allows you to get
into momentum so what can you be proud
of yourself for so love that you showed
up love that you're trying today love
that you're watching this video right
now love that you're making another
attempt even if you fail that a million
other times you're trying again like
love that love that you're starting love
that you're learning love that you're
adapting love that love that you're
gonna put your fourth your best shot
this time and maybe this is the one that
actually sticks like love that about
yourself as opposed to just beating
yourself up and say oh well here I am
again you know another thing that's not
gonna work because again that keeps you
stuck
all of this
does two things it allows you to
actually build the thing that you want
to build
right it allows you to be proud of
yourself it allows you to start getting
more results start getting closer to
your dreams because you're showing up
with love instead of fear right love is
the opposite of fear and two it allows
you to have more fun along the way
so that you're not just constantly
stressed out of jumping from one problem
to another problem to another problem to
another problem because entrepreneurship
is a lot of problems right you have a
lot of problems running your business a
lot and and we're professional
firefighters just constantly putting up
fires so if you can do that would love
it's a lot more fun
this is a lot more fun
so it allows you to be more productive
and effective and it's a lot more fun
and so I think love is a strategy love
is a secret ingredient and it's
something that I need to I'm not perfect
at it I need to constantly remind myself
of it this video is a great refresher
for myself as well and the more that you
can have that as a reminder in your
daily environment as a as a mantra as
something that you live your life by to
choose to show up with love for your
customers for your haters and for
yourself
you can start to embody that even five
percent of the time entire life changes
rule number seven be grateful
appreciation does not equal complacency
one of the biggest things that I think
we struggle as entrepreneurs or as
ambitious people is you feel like if you
start being really appreciative of what
you have then you won't want to go off
and do more and that by being grateful
or being appreciative of what you've got
it's somehow squashes your ambition to
go and create more has you ever thought
about that I have
and what I've realized over the years is
that it's the exact opposite at least
for me that the more I can lean in on
appreciation the more I can lean in on
what I do have it actually gives me the
motivation to want to go off and do more
it feels like it's counterintuitive to
say but for whatever reason it works so
for example whenever
I look at my main Channel we've got
three million subscribers Plus on the
main Channel when I can connect to I'm
so appreciative of having three million
subscribers on my main Channel it gives
me when I can feel it when I when it's
actually in my heart it's like why I
can't believe that we have three million
subscribers that we've got 500 million
views that that more than the population
of the United States in terms of the
views on the channel it sounds crazy
whenever I can actually connect to that
in my heart not just that oh that's
really good like a logical brain thing
but in my heart
it makes me want to do more it makes me
want to serve more makes me want to help
more makes me want to do more videos and
make me feel like what I do matters and
is important and I honestly think that
this is one of the biggest reasons why
I kept going
if you look at my channel the main one
we started in 2009 so many many years
ago and I've posted my progress of how
well the Channel's done over the years
in five years in I had 7 000 subscribers
something like that can you imagine five
years of making videos and you're still
at seven thousand subscribers uh and you
know year one was under 100 subscribers
and anyway you could see the growth on
the website what kept me going
I was shy I was introverted I was scared
to make videos what kept me going what
kept me going what kept me going people
ask me all this how did you not burn out
what kept you going when you weren't
seeing a lot of results
what kept me going was I always focus on
who I was serving instead of who I
wasn't
I did a live stream last night on my uh
much newer gaming channel and we had I
don't know seven people who were
consistent in the chat
why why show up why do it why how is
that not a waste of time you know like
why should I not be doing something else
because I focused on the seven people
who were there
and I ended up making
a great connection for two of the people
there's a guy named Michael who has a
channel focused on helping people
understand people with disabilities and
he brings on able-bodied people to ask
questions that might be uncomfortable
questions about what it's like living
with a disability
and while he was on the live stream last
night I thought of another friend of
mine Nick Tabor and I thought that the
two of them would get along really well
and ended up making a quick introduction
for the two of them and now they're
connected are going to make some content
and and who knows maybe maybe that leads
to know nowhere or maybe they become
best friends and launch a billion dollar
business together I don't know
but it feels like it matters
it feels like yesterday mattered that
that stream yesterday mattered that even
though there are only only seven people
on the stream it felt like it matters it
felt like what I do matters to somebody
and at the end of the day that's what we
all want
you want to feel like you're going to
wake up today and do something that's
gonna matter to somebody in a meaningful
Deep Way
and so you can be grateful for that you
can appreciate that and in knowing that
it inspires me to want to go off and do
more it's not the opposite it's not that
oh I'm so grateful and appreciated that
we had this great session last night and
so now I'm not gonna make any more
content
when appreciate and gratitude for what
you have actually lets you go off and
create more
it puts you in a much better much more
positive much more service mindset to
want to go off and create even bigger
scale things
so in my first videos when I was
struggling and didn't believe in myself
and had no confidence and
this is the only thing I had going for
me was I kept going and why did I keep
going is because I just always for
whatever reason there was no strategy
behind it there was no coach guiding me
I I maybe got lucky or maybe it was just
um great parenting
but I had the mindset of the time that
hey
40 people saw this video
that's really cool
I'm helping somebody
and that's what kept me going
it took me 350 videos before I wasn't
completely embarrassed by myself and 700
videos until I inspired myself with one
of my own videos where I watched it back
and I could finally start feeling proud
700 videos before I finally started
feeling proud of what I was making that
I could watch my own videos back and not
cringe so if that's you if you're
starting and you watch your own videos
back and you think that you suck well
hey that was me too
and it took 700 public videos before I
didn't think that I completely sucked
but I kept going because I felt like it
mattered because at least for one person
maybe you maybe you watching this video
it's still what I use today maybe maybe
this is the video that
encourages you to keep going that
encourages you to be a little more
appreciative that encourages you to
share a little bit more to say yes a
little bit more to take that idea that
you've got in your brain and actually go
and do something on like maybe this is
the video that pushes you just a little
bit forward to go off and do it use it
as permission to say hey I've got great
ideas
and I want to serve and it's finally
time for me to step up
you know it's finally time whether it
works or not I'm gonna try I'm gonna try
a little bit more today because it might
help one person and if this is the video
that gives you the permission to go and
Chase down that idea that's it that's
why I do what I do
and as much as I love the numbers and
it's great you know yes I want to hit 5
million subscribers and 10 million
subscribers and whatever I want to solve
the world's biggest problem right
people don't believe in themselves
enough that's the biggest problem in the
world I'm never gonna do it and I wake
up every day trying to do it but the
thing that keeps me going
is the appreciation and gratitude for
what I have done and what I have in my
life
you could stretch that to gratitude for
your health I actually just came back
from the doctor's office
um I'm getting
immunotherapy done where I I used to
have really bad allergies to trees like
there trees and grass would cause crazy
allergies and I discovered immunotherapy
where they basically put a little bit of
tree and grass under your skin once a
month and slowly your body gets used to
it so now I can walk out without having
allergies I used to be taking two
allergy pills a day from early spring to
late fall almost the entire year just
winter off because I struggled so much
with my allergies
and now I don't
and in being grateful and appreciative
of my health even as I'm saying these
words out loud where my brain goes next
is I want to have more health
so it's the opposite right we think that
if you're grateful and appreciative for
what you have you won't be ambitious and
want more but it's the opposite as I
think about my health and how grateful I
am to not have allergies right now to
not be struggling right now to not be on
multiple allergy pills right now
now I wanna now I want to be healthier
now now I want to go for a run now I
want to make a extra salad like I want
to invest more in my health because
there's momentum behind it
and so wherever you apply appreciation
and gratitude you'll see that area of
your life start to multiply
so if you're grateful for the
relationships in your life you'll see
those relationships get better if you're
appreciative for what you've done in
your business so far even though it's
not where you want to be listen you're
never going to be where you want to be
but if you're grateful and appreciative
for what you have done already in your
business it'll give you momentum to go
and create more
so wherever you apply gratitude and
appreciation that area of your life will
multiply will get better we'll continue
to improve
I want you to think about the opposite
you know again we we think that
gratitude and appreciation leads to
complacency
it doesn't
we think that being appreciative for
what we have makes us less of an
ambitious person it doesn't it's the
opposite lean in on gratitude and
appreciation and watch your entire life
change rule number eight set your
Healthy boundaries the key to getting
the life that you want is figuring out
what you're going to say no to you can
get anything that you want you just
can't get everything that you want all
at once and if you're feeling like
you're behind you're unhappy you're not
getting anywhere close to your goals
you're not getting any kind of momentum
towards achieving anything then you have
to start really examining what are you
going to say no to where do we need to
raise the bar raise our standards and
stop saying yes to people to ideas that
don't ultimately serve where you want to
go so my son just finished having a
month off of school and so I had them
for a whole month no school and I
decided for that month that I would
spend a lot of time with him that
instead of him just being over and he
working and spending evenings together
that I would I would spend most of the
time with him so I was I went from
working one of our normal work hours are
down to 10 10 of the work hours are
canceled almost all of my meetings I
canceled almost all of my calls I didn't
do any Instagram lives the only ongoing
one that I kept was my movement makers
and branalytics program that I that I
train on Thursdays and that was almost
it I still stayed on top of email but I
wasn't doing most of the things that I
was normally doing I said no to most
things I said no to media opportunities
I said no to speaking opportunities I
said no to new ideas for this YouTube
channel and my other YouTube channels I
said no to almost everything I put up a
boundary for the month because I wanted
to be able to spend the time with my son
and we had an amazing time and it was
awesome and I took him to La he wanted
to be an actor so he took him to LA and
we went on some of the studio tours in
the Hollywood Walk of Fame and all of
that fun stuff it was his first time
there and it was amazing I don't regret
any of it and also when I came back
there was a mountain of work that I had
to do there's a mountain of emails to
get back to there's a mountain of uh
people that I needed to connect with and
so it's just making a decision as to
what do I want in my life especially
right now and are the things that I'm
doing leading me towards it or not and
if there's people that are not just
getting in your way but people who are
bringing you down people who are pulling
you off in a different direction
everybody has an agenda for your life
right everybody has ideas for what you
should be doing with your life
and we're constantly being pulled in a
million different directions so how do
you know which is the right one to do
well the process that I go through is I
start by one figuring out what is what
is my most important core value so mine
is believe right what is your most
important core value if you're being
pulled in many different directions by
all sorts of people who have plans for
what you should do with your life
until you understand what you stand for
as a human you're going to constantly
being be pulled in all those Milling
directions and never feel like you have
any safe spot to stand on you're going
to feel like you're in quicksand all the
time so what is your single most
important core value maybe one already
comes to mind maybe you've already done
this exercise you already know it but
that's a constant reminder and if you
don't know what your most important core
value is I go through it in year one
word and build the serve but basically
think about all the things that have
made you come alive the people that
you've loved the movies you loved
watching your favorite teacher of all
time what's the common thread between
all of them it's a feeling it's an
emotion your favorite teacher growing up
wasn't because they taught you mine was
mad I'm far it wasn't because she taught
me French it's because she made me
believe in myself more right so all
those great things that made you come
alive what's the consistent thread
between those things and that's what you
need more of right now and it's what you
need more of in the future going into
your life so the projects that don't
feel right the people who are pushing
you in the wrong direction it could be
from a really loving place but if it
doesn't match up with your most
important core Value Plus the goals that
you're trying to accomplish then then
it's not a fit and I don't I don't think
you have to have necessarily tough
conversations with toxic people just
stop spending time with them
you know just stop spending as much time
with them if there's people who are
constantly negative around you just stop
spending time with them raise the bar
for what you accept into your life
you know and so the willingness to say
no to understand that you can't have
everything but you can have anything and
being super clear on what that anything
is and by going after that anything
like going after your big goals it
requires you to say no to other things
and this isn't just a business thing
this is for any goal that you've got if
you've got a health goal right if you've
got a health goal
while you you can have anything you want
you can go have pizza and donuts and
beer and whatever you can go eat that
you'll feel great in the moment but you
can't have you can't have everything
because you'll end up being overweight
and unhealthy and and not probably not
happy with your life if you are happy
great keep going off and doing it but
you know this morning I've got my my
coffee I go on I believe walk every
morning I spend time thinking about what
I want today to look like I'm making
YouTube videos with my intention I'm
going to want to put out there to the
world go get a coffee for myself and
Nina and it's and it's just a coffee
it's not what I love to go to Tim
Hortons this Canadian brand if you don't
know Tim Hortons and get a farmer's wrap
with bacon and sausage and egg and hash
brown in a Boston cream donut of course
my mouth is water as I'm saying all that
stuff but I'm not doing it because I've
got a health goal and so I can have
anything but I can't have everything and
so it's the willingness to say no to
those other things that may even bring
you some kind of short-term benefit but
are in alignment with who you want to be
so it's getting really clear on on who
you are what's your most important core
value and then what are the goals that
you want for yourself and then the
things that do that no longer kind of
match up the activities if you want to
hit your goals it's the activities and
the habits that you're doing on a daily
basis right eating eating a donut every
now and then it's not the end of the
world eating the donut every day you're
gonna not hit your health goals so it's
more about what are you doing
consistently every day if you're around
negative people constantly
every day you're going to be a lot more
negative if you're on them every now and
then it's not going to make that big of
an impact so you are where you
consistently do and so it's choosing to
show up in a certain way to say no and
sending boundaries and raising the
standard for what you consistently
accept into your life and it's a choice
it's a decision and you don't have to
make some giant decision like I'm only
going to hang around millionaires now I
mean you could if you want but a lot of
these decisions are made in increments
that it's much more important what are
you doing today and then tomorrow and
then the next day and these micro
improvements that you're going to make
where you're
constantly and never endingly is that a
word never endingly never endingly
raising the bar for what you accept into
your life and one of my favorite ways to
do it is content is videos if you feel
like
you're kind of stuck and you haven't
grown in a while and the friends around
you are just thinking small and they're
they're not inspiring you and you feel
stuck if you look back on the past year
of your life have you grown are you
further ahead do you know more are you
more confident have you accomplished
more are you moving closely towards your
goals are you proud of the person that
you have become right in the past year
and if no then it's changing the
environment to be around the people who
are like who you want to be and I find
content is the best way to do it it's
why I make these videos it's why I do my
main channel it's why I do so much
content that whether you're learning
from me or Bill Gates or Oprah Winfrey
or Tony Robbins or Lisa Nichols or
whoever that there's always something
every day to be there for you um I
believe walks in the morning I always
listen to one of my videos so on my walk
on the walk to get the coffee I'm
usually doing uh videos myself or
responding to people on Instagram and
DMS and just sending out love and
feeling like I'm part of the community
and the work I do matters and then on
the way back because I have two cups of
coffee in my hand I can't record videos
so I'm listening and watching uh one of
the videos from my channel and I love
starting my day with a Warren Buffett or
an Elon Musk or whoever in my ears
because it pushes me forward no matter
how big I'm thinking how great I am the
work that I'm doing I love being around
people who are doing more and it pushes
me forward and no matter how great a day
I had yesterday
today feels like a new day
you have the greatest day of all time
yesterday but that that buzz that high
Fades the feeling like your Unstoppable
Fades and so it's having that as a
consistent again you are what you
consistently do having that is a
consistent part of your routine is being
surrounded by the people even if you
don't have them as friends but videos
podcasts books of the people who are
thinking living acting like the way you
want to and the more that you're around
them the more they will pull you forward
to accomplishing the things you want to
accomplish and you becoming the person
you want to be so you can have anything
you want you can have anything you want
you just can't have everything
and the difference between where you are
now and where you want to be is what and
who you are now going to start saying no
to because you've raised your standards
rule number nine find your purpose your
vision comes from your purpose and your
purpose comes from your pain when people
ask me all the time how do I find my
purpose how do I find my one of the
number one questions people have well
it's actually pretty easy to find your
purpose you just have to understand that
it comes from your pain whatever you
struggled with the most as a human being
in your life is the thing that you want
to help other people through
and that may be something on a big scale
where you want to change the world and
make sure that it never happens to
anybody else ever again and ease the
suffering for others along the journey
if you're watching this video you're on
this channel it's probably more the way
that you lean but it could also just be
the people closest to you
the closest members in your family that
your closest friends the the team that
you're on your co-workers those are the
people who you want to help the most you
don't have to go off and change the
world but you do have to feel like what
you do matters at the end of the day all
of us want to make sure that we wake up
and we feel like today is going to
matter
when you feel like today matters to
somebody that you can be doing work that
is unservice to other people that you
will matter to them that what you create
today will matter to them it's going to
make you feel better it's going to make
you feel alive it's going to make you
feel worthy it's going to make you feel
proud of yourself however when you wake
up and you feel like today doesn't
matter like nobody cares if you show up
that your work will be meaningless
you're just going to toil away and do
useless things we probably all had jobs
like that right if you had a job like
that you woke up you went to your work
felt like you're just gonna plug away
even if you were working hard but it
just didn't matter there's no
appreciation the work either did matter
it didn't matter if you showed up or not
but that's I think most people we've at
least had a job like that at some point
in our past and that's the path down to
feeling worthless and depression anxiety
and suicide a lot of the problems that
we're facing a lot of for for a lot of
people the biggest problem is just you
don't feel like the work you're doing is
meaning anything to anybody and and
therefore you feel like you don't matter
because because the work you're doing is
not meaning anything to other people
therefore you don't matter because deep
down we all want to serve you were built
to serve we all want to feel like what
we do matters so you don't have to
necessarily have a big vision for the
world but you do have to figure out your
purpose
when your purpose comes from your pain
so for me I struggled so much as an
entrepreneur
as a 19 year old getting this first
business off the ground and turning down
the big jobs and failing and sucking and
making no money and just pouring
everything I had into this company and
being absolutely broke
financially and and emotionally you know
the initial high of I'm going to start a
business I'm going to be an entrepreneur
and we're going to do this we're going
to change the world yeah uh what's great
and then it wears off when you realize
nothing is happening we're barely
getting any customers we're barely
making any money the the the the high of
the launch Fades pretty quickly and then
you're in the muck of actually just
trying to create things and I really
struggled and those were the worst days
of my life
um it led to some of the best days uh
but just the worst days emotionally
feeling like I was worthless
and so that's why I do what I do
because I want to help all the 19 year
old Evans out there not struggle as much
as I struggled not be as embarrassed to
ask for help not to be as ashamed to
feel like a total failure not to feel
like I'm going through this alone not to
have zero mentors and building this up
not to pretend like everything is great
when it's not and it's not only talking
to 19 year olds around the world you
know it could be you it could be a 52
year old woman and it was going through
the same thing it's that emotion and so
I love helping I love helping a lot of
big people with their channels and their
businesses but uh my heart is really in
the startup because that's where I
really struggled the most myself and so
that's what I'm trying to create an
everyday wake up and and try to do
something else whether it's a YouTube
video or a tick tock or an Instagram or
write the book or speak an engagement
and whatever the next thing is VR Evan
and hologram Evan and 3D Evan and
whatever beaming into your living room
this is something forever when people
ask me how do you how have you not burnt
out how have you how do you keep going
so many years later thousands of videos
later
well I I feel like I'm living my purpose
it's another I record videos on Tuesday
it's another Tuesday sitting here in the
car and my wife is at her acupuncture
appointment and I'm I joined her and I'm
I've got my coffee and I'm sitting in
the car making videos and this is video
number I don't know how many thousand
and why keep going well because I feel
like this video will mean something to
at least one person
maybe it hits a million people maybe it
hits one person but it's going to be
valuable to at least one person and when
you can feel that when you can genuinely
feel that that you're making something
that's gonna actually touch at least one
human being
that's a good that's a good addiction to
get you know to feel like we matter so
think back to what was the most painful
moment of your life
you want to find your vision you want to
find your purpose what's the most
painful moment of your life when did you
struggle the most as a human when did
you feel the most worthless useless it
doesn't mean that you were suicidal
though maybe you were but it also
doesn't mean that you're in depression
you know maybe you were but when did you
just feel the lowest I never had any
Suicidal Thoughts I don't think I was
depressed either but I felt really low
when was that moment for you what were
the worst days of your life and your
purpose is then to help other people who
are struggling with that's very same
thing because you've made it through
and it it doesn't mean that you're done
growing and learning I'm I'm still
learning I'm still growing that's why I
still watch videos and make videos
because I'm I'm still learning and
that's great you want to climb you climb
forever you never want to stop
progressing and stop climbing that's the
whole idea you know beyond the mountain
there's more Mountains you wanna you
wanna climb forever swim forever play
the game forever there is no Finish Line
that's the best part of it and every
time you take another step you reach
back and you help somebody get to where
you're at
and so you've learned a lot of lessons
if you think about who you used to be go
back to that moment where you were
struggling the most and that person you
know for me it's probably sitting at my
business partner's dining room table
uh just frustrated
lost tried everything nothing's working
how am I here why did I say no to that
job why did I say yes to this what did I
just throw away everything my whole life
you know it would be overly dramatic but
that's what was going through my mind
is what I was actually thinking so I had
it had you know what could I what would
I go back and tell that Evan so for you
what was the most painful moment in your
life imagine a picture it see yourself
there who are you with where are you you
know what's the setting around you and
imagine you can go back and talk to that
person younger you you had 15 minutes
with that person what would you say
you could help that person
you don't have to be Simon sinek or Tony
Robbins or Oprah Winfrey whoever you can
go back and help younger you
can give them some advice and in fact
younger you would probably listen to you
a lot more than they would listen to me
or Simon Sonic or Tony Robbins Oprah
Winfrey or whoever because you've gone
through it they know who you are they
know that you understand them and so
they need your help
and that's that's what you create
whether it's making YouTube videos
whether it's some product or service
that you end up selling whether it's
joining some other organization who has
a similar Vision that you're going to
tie yourself to
but that's what you want to do that will
make your life meaningful that will make
you feel valuable that'll make you feel
connected to the thing that you're
waking up every day doing I think
ultimately that's what makes people
happy
and so your vision comes from your
purpose your purpose comes from your
pain
and if you felt like you're reaching
back and touching younger you and
helping make sure that other people
don't have to struggle and suffer as
much as you did
that's the answer
the fulfillness happiness money and most
importantly
feeling like you are proud of yourself
and that you matter rule number 10 the
last one before our very special bonus
clip move towards your goals stop
focusing on 10-year goals and worry
about what's in front of you right now I
think people spend too much time
worrying about their their life plan
about their five-year goals their
10-year goals think about where you were
10 years ago who were you what were your
goals what did you think was possible
ten years ago you know I'm I'm 40 how
old am I Nina 40 41 am I 41. I'm 42 soon
wow so 42 when I was 32 did I predict
that I'd be here no think about where
you were 10 years ago could you with any
degree of confidence say this is where
I'm gonna be in 10 years and and this is
what ended up happening there's no way
like you from 10 years ago has no idea
what you're capable of and and that's
the point like if you're growing if
you're learning if you're improving if
you're getting better then you have no
idea what you're capable of doing in the
10-year window
just don't all you can do is the best
guess if you're going to project forward
10 years it's the best guess of where
you're at right now and it can still be
a useful exercise
come up with a list
goals of where you want to be in five
years or ten years can still be a useful
exercise for where you are right now the
challenge with it why I'm not a huge fan
of it is because it often then leads to
you locking yourself in because if you
are growing and you're learning and
you're improving and you're getting
better you're watching videos like this
you care about you know improving
yourself
then you honestly should jump off your
10-year goals two years in
16 months in maybe three months in
because you've learned something new and
now this is a better path for you
if you can with precision
hit your 10-year goals then I think
you're thinking small
you're thinking small you're living a
boxed in life you know you're uh your
at a very boring job and you know the
path up and that's where you're going to
be in 10 years I think if you love your
life and you're learning and you're
growing you have no idea what you're
capable of in attend your window
okay so if 10-year goals aren't the
answer then what then what's the answer
how do I get some kind of Direction and
Clarity for what I should do with my
life well I divide into two things one
is you've got your purpose and then
you've got what's in front of you so the
purpose is something that will will
never change your I believe your purpose
comes from your pain so two of the most
important exercises you can ever do is
to figure out your who and your why and
I go through this and build the serve my
book but you're who is your single most
important core value mine is believe
figure out what yours is that gives you
Clarity for the rest of your life what I
want to create is things that help me
believe in myself more and then I can
spread more belief to the world as well
right what is your single most important
core value if you feel lost you're
struggling you feel like you're pulled
in a million different directions
everybody's got some agenda for your
time your challenge is you don't know
what you stand for so figure that out
your single most important value you're
who your why is your purpose your
purpose comes from your pain so whatever
you struggled with the most is the thing
you want to help other people through
whatever challenges hurdles that you
overcome the most important ones at the
times when you felt the most useless as
a human there are other people right now
millions of people right now who are
struggling with that same exact thing
and your purpose is to help them not
feel as isolated as a loan uh and help
them not struggle as much so for me it
was helping entrepreneurs because I
struggled so much as an entrepreneur so
belief plus entrepreneurship right
because that's my who and my why so for
you what is your single most important
core value and then what is your pain
that you you experience the most and in
that combination is what you'll love
doing for the rest of your life for the
rest of your life they all be I'll be
120 years old 200 years old who knows
how long we'll be living and I'll still
love
believing in entrepreneurs forever it
never gets old it doesn't go away if
anything it only gets stronger and
that's why I think it's one of the most
important exercises not the most
important two exercises you can ever do
in your life because it helps you
understand your life going backwards but
more importantly that helps you plan a
better life going forward
who do you want to be what do you what
is the work that you want to do that
will be of service and in helping others
and make you feel like your life has
meaning
and allow you to be proud of yourself
that is a high level
of what you want to do for the rest of
your life figuring out your who and your
why right most important value and your
your purpose okay it doesn't really give
a lot of guidance of like what exactly
to do right it doesn't dive into a lot
of the tactics like okay what do I wake
up and do today if I want to believe in
entrepreneurs it's still pretty big it's
still a pretty wide uh purpose a pretty
wide Mission what do I wanna what do I
actually want to do today well that's
where you connect to
whatever's in front of you right now
what are you most attached to what are
you most emotional about what is your
heart telling you to go off and do and
less about 10 in 10 years I want to have
a New York Times best-selling book or
insert whatever you know goal that you
think is Meaningful to you and much more
about what would make me come alive
right now
trust in that instinct so right now it's
making YouTube videos so we're in the
car we're on the way to Costco you just
got some stuff to buy and
I'm making videos because I feel like
this matters this is going to reach
somebody because not just all my videos
but this video right now this one
specifically may be for you this is this
is the moment where things shift and
change maybe this is the one that gives
you the permission to go and do
something bigger maybe it gives you the
confidence or the courage to say yes to
the idea that you've got in the back
your mind that you've been delaying a
little bit too long on procrastinating a
little bit too long on fearful that it
won't work out and this is the video
that helps you push forward and do it at
least that's what I'm telling myself
that for one person this is gonna be the
video that makes a change that's how I
am able to to get up and do these things
otherwise
you land in the land of what's the point
and if you're stuck in what's the point
line then you don't make anything that's
that's the brakes on everything that you
want out of life and so you've got your
vision you know you've got your purpose
what are you trying to accomplish right
you've got your most important core
value and then you've got what's in
front of you what do you work on right
now and how excited are you buying a lot
of times people come to me and they've
got their list of all the things that
they could do I could do this or I could
do that or I could do this what are you
most excited by how many of those things
on your list are because you think you
should do them or because somebody told
you that you should do them versus
you're actually jazzed about doing it
when I first started doing videos I
sucked at it
uh being introverted and shy and not
knowing any of the technical stuff and
the gear and I really struggled at it
and and there was nothing on paper
um that would have led itself to me
being a content creator right of the
career tests or whatever would never
have pointed towards something like this
but I made a video because I felt like
it
and I liked it I wasn't very good at it
I wasn't getting any results from it but
I liked it I enjoyed it and that is the
thing that allowed me to keep going
so out of all the things that are on
your list or ideas what do you feel most
attached to what are you most energetic
by what would get you going that it
doesn't feel like work to show up and do
these things but it's actually fun the
process not just the result of helping
somebody but the actual process of doing
the the work feels good to you it's
exciting to you what is that thing and
then go do it and if you can match those
two things
setting setting goals is relatively easy
saying you want to have a New York Times
best-selling book in the next 10 years
it's an easy goal to pick the problem
with it is that you're not emotionally
connected to it enough it doesn't mean
enough to you what does that actually
mean
and it's still set by a person who's not
capable of thinking on a 10-year Horizon
because you're going to be a different
person 10 years from now you'll still
have the same core values but you're
going to be stronger you're going to
know more you have a lot more experience
the world will be different the
opportunities will be completely
different right where was I 10 years ago
on YouTube
not very far a couple hundred
subscribers would I say I'm gonna have
three million subscribers on my YouTube
channel no I didn't think that was
possible with being a YouTuber wasn't
even a thing
so you don't know what the world holds
for you so you've got your most
important core value
you're who you've got your purpose which
is your why that comes from your pain
and then you've got what's in front of
you right
and don't over judge and over analyze
you don't have the next 18 steps lined
up for yourself for what you should be
doing with your life because nobody's
got that and if you've got that then
you're thinking small because you don't
know what you're capable of so don't
over stress Don't over analyze and the
most important thing is take that if
you've done the work on the high level
to figure out your who and your why
then what's in front of you right now
that you're excited about that you could
do that is of service to other people
and get going
because you've got the heart you've got
the energy you've got the capability
you've got the passion you've got the
desire and the willingness to serve
you just gotta get out and start doing
it
get going believe
stop thinking that you should be
Fearless if you go through life Fearless
that means you are playing small and not
doing anything that is worth doing you
should be dreaming big you should be
pushing boundaries and in that push
comes fear instead of trying to be
Fearless adopt a mindset that you want
to feel the fear and do it anyway
otherwise you will never tick on big
projects and you'll never accomplish
your mission and you'll always live
below the potential that you know you're
capable of your environment has been
perfectly created to keep you exactly
where you are everything around you your
friends your family the media you
consume all keeps you exactly where you
are if you want to raise your standards
and raise the quality of your life it
starts with raising your environment so
here's a story I haven't told in a while
when I was building up my YouTube
channel and I closed my first multi-year
deal with the Big Brand it was with a
CEO high-powered CEO one of the largest
companies in the world World especially
in The Entrepreneur Space and it was
going to be me and him on my channel
every month answering questions from you
guys from the audience we did a live
stream every month and it wasn't me
interviewing him or him interviewing me
it was both of us talking about a
certain topic and then taking questions
and I remember driving with my dad he
was getting a new car and we had this
long drive out for whatever reason the
place that we wanted to buy the car was
super far away and so it gave us this
chance to talk in a car and I just told
him about this new deal that I had
signed I remember him asking me Evan
what gives you the confidence to feel
like you're on the same level as this
guy and he didn't mean it in a in a
negative way it was it was in a more
awestruck way it's like man look at
where you've come from because my family
is very humble like you have to be very
humble you have to appreciate what
you've got and so how am I now how do I
see myself on the same stage as his
high-powered CEOs being his equal
answering questions
and the question took me back and I
thought you know what he's right I mean
if this was Evan of five years prior I
would have felt not worthy I would have
felt like I couldn't do it I would have
felt like this is too big an opportunity
for me like I couldn't be the guy to do
it so what changed five years ago to
where I was at that point it was my
content it was my channel it was all the
videos that I'm I'm putting up because
in my head it was a big deal in that
this was the largest deal I had signed
for three years but more of that I'm
around Oprah every day and and then
paying every day and Kanye West every
day and all these people every day and
so I feel like I'm with them
and and so this CEO deal wasn't that
huge a deal
because I had changed my environment
right I'd raised the stakes in my
environment and that raises your
standards and so I realized man this is
crazy how important my channel is to
myself at least to my own growth if it's
not to you at least to my own growth
because you often can't see it on a
daily basis I could not pinpoint the one
video I uploaded or the one day that I
felt this is it it's happened
but if I look back over a five-year
period a one-year period a six-month
period even a three month period think
about who you were three months ago if
you're invested in yourself by watching
these videos or reading books or
anything else if you're investing in
yourself even just look three months
back and think have I grown how much
have you grown in the past three months
you may not see it on a daily basis but
with months and then more months and
then more months and then years if you
keep on the path you'll see some
tremendous results may not even
recognize the person who you used to be
and that's why it's so important that
you raise your environment what would
the boldest version of you do think
about your mission
trying to
do it now but think about what the
boldest version of you if you summon the
boldest version of you into existence
right now what would he or she tell you
to do so when I did my tour earlier this
year was 90 days 23 cities and at first
I want to do it for free I love doing
free coffee shop meetups every time I
travel to a new city and I told my agent
Steve from New York hey man this is my
idea he said you need to charge for the
event you got to play bigger you gotta
you gotta do a bolder version of you and
it it's freaked me out it scared me
because I don't want to disappoint
people and the idea of charging for
something and then me disappointing
people and then hitting that fear every
four days because I got up in a new city
every three to four days for 90 days was
me being able to conquer my fears and so
Steve pushed me and I have Steve's voice
in my head it's like you need to play
bigger you got to do something Bolder
what's the next step and so I'm looking
at my next tour coming up in 2020 around
my book built the serve and I'm trying
to think how do I make it even bigger
how do I make it even bold older because
what I've done has been great and it's
not trying to take away from what I've
done it's amazing I'm proud of myself
I'm grateful awesome and I know I'm
capable of more and I know I need to do
something at the next level because if I
want to go off and accomplish my mission
I need to because at the rate I'm going
right now I'm not going to hit a billion
people I'm not going to solve the
world's biggest problem
I'm not going to have the impact and
reach that I know I can have unless I
demand more boldness bigger scale from
myself on a daily basis and so for me
having Steve's voice in my head having
Elon Musk voice in my head having Steve
Jobs and epiganini and my parents and
Kanye West and Howard Schultz constantly
my head the content that I make is for
myself
it's selfish for myself and then I share
with you guys and thankfully you like it
so I could build a business around it
and hire your team and keep creating
more
what makes you bold what makes you come
alive and how do you summon that
creature on a daily basis when you if
you wake up and you daily every day
consistently are bringing the boldest
version of you even for one year if you
woke up every day for one year and
summoned the boldest version of you your
life is gonna look dramatically
different one year from today if you are
not focused on your goals you either
don't want them or you are afraid of
them you might just not want to do them
you might be in the wrong thing you
might have picked the wrong goals for
the wrong reasons or you're afraid of
your goals you're afraid of failing
you're afraid of it not working out and
what that means either way the answer is
action if you don't love it move on
immediately and if you're afraid of it
move into it immediately focused action
is always the answer so one of the
entrepreneurs that I've invested into
his name is Alex he helps me run Toronto
dance salsa which is the largest salsa
dance school in Canada maybe North
America and we're sitting down reviewing
his goals and reviewing his habits and
making sure that you know what he said
he was going to do matches to him
accomplishing his goals and there were a
couple things that were big things on
the list that he had to get done and he
was afraid of making a mistake so for
example we're trying to create the
interior of the studio and make a wall
that speaks to the purpose of the
company speaks to the the mission the
vision what we're trying to accomplish
and we want to have something beautiful
that people want to take their pictures
on and he's so afraid of getting it
right he's so afraid of doing the wrong
thing that he does nothing and every
time he opens up the file to look at
what he wants to do and different ideas
he's afraid he's going to make a mistake
he's afraid he's going to invest time
energy dollars my money into something
and then when people show up saying huh
and it doesn't work out he's so afraid
to fail that he doesn't take action
which becomes the biggest failure of all
so here is our solution procrastination
Power Hour said every day PPH
put it into your calendar for one hour
this is your PPH time the thing that you
have been procrastinated on right the
thing that serves the business if if
you've been procrastinating on it and
you don't like it and it doesn't serve
the business great get rid of it that's
not what we're talking about it's the
things that you're afraid of the things
that you don't want to make a mistake on
that you're just pushing aside because
there's all those busy work that comes
in because yes we have to respond to
customers and yes we got to do all the
work that goes into the day-to-day of
running the company
but if you're so focused on just the
day-to-day and never focus on the things
that will actually help you grow the
bigger picture stuff then guess what
happens you never do the bigger picture
stuff especially if it's because you're
afraid then you have to take action so
we plan the daily procrastination Power
Hour that he puts into his calendar and
he looks at it when he gets there he
thinks what am I procrastinating the
most time and he's got this list and he
starts attacking it and having that in
his calendar is a thing that actually
started building momentum for those big
projects Paul Newman the legendary actor
had an amazing quote that I love to
repeat he said I check my pulse and if I
can find it I know I've got a chance
you've got a very important choice to
make you either make the rest of your
life the best of your life or you settle
for what is and live in your excuses so
you know why I would give up you know
what I'm deeply afraid of I've got two
I've got a short-term fear and a
long-term fear my short-term fear is of
disappointing people my biggest short
term in the moment fear is disappointing
people that I would show up to an event
and let people down that I wouldn't give
them value that people would come and
waste their time spend their money and I
didn't give them value I'm deeply afraid
of it and still that I put pressure on
these videos I want these videos to be
great every time I get in front of this
camera and start making a video I put
pressure myself that this seems to be
the best video that I've ever done I
want to not disappoint you guys every
single time and this little pause
hesitation
before filming and I'll spend a couple
minutes procrastinating because I'm I'm
afraid I'm afraid of disappointing you
and making a crappy video I'll
procrastinate and then I'll do it and
I'll feel great doing it but my biggest
short-term fear disappointing people my
biggest long-term fear is of regret is
that I won't live my life is that I'll
look back and say I could have done more
I I should have pushed harder because
you rarely regret the things that you
did it's the things that you didn't do
the things you were too afraid to do the
action's not taken that's what you
normally regret
and so my biggest short-term appearance
is important people maybe it's the
long-term fear is fear of regret and
those things
they fight each other
right they fight each other because if
I'm afraid of disappointing somebody I'm
not going to take the action that I
should be taking and then I'm going to
regret it later on
and so I try to use that to your
potential regret to push me into action
to say if I don't make videos today if I
don't do that speech if I don't get up
and make that presentation if I don't do
the thing that I'm afraid to do
because of disappointing people
potentially then I'll regret it and I'll
put the pressure like this is the video
this video right here this is a video
that's gonna blow up everything that'll
change the whole game for me and if I
don't record it because I'm afraid of
disappointing somebody I'm gonna regret
that my whole life and I make it so
painful for myself that then I have to
act and that pain pushes me into action
and out of procrastination mode when did
you decide that your dreams shouldn't be
big when did you decide that you
shouldn't tell anyone else about your
dreams until you own your dreams and
stop making yourself feel small those
dreams will never happen
now this is something
everybody we're worried about playing a
bigger game we're worried about thinking
bigger for ourselves and we're worried
about telling other people because what
if it doesn't work out what if we don't
make it what's that judgment gonna come
how are they going to think about us and
so I think about my own story when I'm
trying to create the biggest fight that
I used to get into with my agent Steve
was he says Evan you need to be a
household name you need to be famous
like Steve I don't want to be famous
i i i equated famous to Ego if you're
famous and you're just big egomaniac I
didn't I don't want to be an egomaniac
it's not it's not about me it's about
spreading belief I don't I I'm nervous
getting in front of the camera even
before filming this video I'm nervous
like I wanted to wanted to do well the
lights come on I don't crave it I don't
crave attention I'm an introvert I like
just doing my thing Evan you need to get
famous why Steve why do we need to get
famous
and for maybe two years we fought over
this because I kept equating Fame with
ego and I looked at the people who were
famous and like I don't want to be like
them and there's a lot that they did
that that bothered me and I wanted to do
it a different way and that's the key
it's finding the different way to do it
how does an introvert on a mission
become famous I don't know we're gonna
go on this journey together and
hopefully find out what finally a click
for me was him saying when you get
famous your mission will spread
if you start tying actions to Mission
that's how you get me to move for other
people might be hey I'll give you all
this money if you do this or you'll have
the fame or or credibility or have
statues but I don't need statues built
of me but as soon as you tie it to
Mission and service that gets me going
so he said if you actually want
to fulfill your mission if you say you
want to spread belief then you need to
get famous because the more people know
about you the more people will hear your
message and if finally it finally stuck
like okay I gotta do it I don't know how
to do it I've never I've never tried to
do it I've I've always wanted to be
behind the spotlight and so now now this
is part of my mission I need to become a
household name and get famous so that
more people can believe in themselves if
I actually want to solve the world's
biggest problem
then I need to be out there doing it I
need to believe in myself more
right if I'm trying to spread belief I
need to believe in myself more too
and so I think that's a human condition
that's part of what we want to do you
want to step outside your comfort zone
you want to serve humans are built to
serve we are we are built to serve but
service requires helping other people
and because we're afraid of judgment
you don't want to do it you've got your
foot in the gas and a break at the same
time you want to help people but you're
worried about their judgment so you
don't do anything you know you're
capable of more you know you're capable
of more but you don't do it because
you're afraid you need people in your
life to hold you accountable because you
will never push yourself as hard as you
can go you get a personal trainer not
because of what exercises you should do
you can look that up online the real
value of a trainer is to have somebody
right there in front of you in your face
telling you to do three more reps of
that exercise when you want to quit when
you're gonna tap out and if you're by
yourself you'd say I'm done and they say
give me three more because all of the
growth happens in that last set if
there's nobody around you to hold you to
a higher standard you'll always know
that there's another level but you'll be
too afraid to reach for yourself so
[Music]
have in the books and the speaking
everything I do I want to go up and do
this impossible thing that's never going
to happen I'm never going to solve the
world's biggest problem and yet I wake
up every day and I try to do it and I
use a combination of what I call
aspirational mentors which are people
like Steve Jobs and Elon Musk and the
people that I profile on this channel
and then I also do it from people who
challenge me one-on-one if you watch my
entrepreneur advice Channel I get pushed
every week by my agent Steve by
psychologists in Australia by people who
are coaching me and how to get better
and they push me and they tell me I need
to do more and they tell me I'm being an
idiot in these areas and like go this is
the homework
and the more uncomfortable I feel during
that process usually the better the
advice is if I think about the tour that
I launched last year and now the tour
that I'm doing this year
it started as a free tour and became a
paid tour when my agency pushed me to do
it
but you need to charge for this and
immediately my heart's boom boom boom
boom boom I'm scared means I have to do
it
having people around you who can push
you to do the things that you need to do
who make you nervous who make you scared
who see your blind spots who cut through
your BS
who tell you that's just fear talking
because we'll come up with really
logical reasons why we can't do
something
or aspirational mentors who when you see
how they react to things how they see
things how they understand the world and
then you look at what you're doing it
forces you to be pulled up it forces you
to take the next step up on the
staircase you need to do it because your
environment's been perfectly designed to
keep you where you are your friends your
family all of it it's keeping you
exactly where you are and the difference
between where you are now and where you
want to be and where you can be in a
year in two years in five years in 10
years is going to be the people you have
around you and how much they're willing
to push you to believe in you to tell
you what you may not want to hear but
you need to hear to grow to challenge
yourself and get to the next level earn
yourself to other people can be a
fantastic thing a fantastic thing but
there's only one way to make it work you
have to kick yourself forward not down
you kick yourself forward not down most
people here's what they do most people
you see someone who's that success you
see somebody with a Ferrari or a car or
somebody who you're jealous of or you're
insecure about yourself when you're
around them you see them and you you
think you suck you look at them and say
I suck why am I not further ahead why is
Dan who's not even 40 years old yet have
all of the success and here I am and I'm
not doing it yet
right you kick yourself down that's how
most people do it and in public you
might tell your friends how that person
is a scumbag you stole he's ripping
people off he's a jerk but when you go
home you just tell yourself man why am I
not for their head why am I why am I
here why am I stuck why am I not getting
more momentum you've been kicked but
you've been kicked down
where what you want to do is kick
yourself forward
you want to kick yourself forward if you
see Dan driving his Ferrari or you see
somebody that you look up to and respect
uses the kick forward to say this is
what's possible
this is why it's possible and if he can
do it if she can do it then I can do it
too
my hero is Young Les Brown I love him
from a speaker just my favorite speaker
of all time I look at that and I say I
can get better
not that I suck it's that this is what's
possible I need to get better I need to
improve I need to practice I need to
keep going because that's what's
possible people think that closing is a
bad word that sales people are slimy and
closing someone on something is good for
you but not necessarily good for them
now some people are like that but it
doesn't have to be you you want to help
people and if you know that they should
be taking action in an area where they
are not their ability to follow through
and listen to your advice is directly in
relation to your ability to close them
if you want to help people you need to
learn how to close I was really in this
same camp you know I I thought sales
people were slimy
um I'm I'm a humble Canadian with humble
parents and never really learned about
sales and techniques and closing because
that's what bad people do you know and
my my passion is to live a life of
service and I saw my mom do it you know
she's on the wall behind me and all the
great efforts that she went through to
help help humanity and the people around
her and there was a moment in time I
realized that there was this one moment
that this is when I needed to learn how
to get better at closing this is when I
realized I need to I need to learn this
skill because if I don't it's going to
limit my impact
that I want to build that I want to help
people right it's going to live my
impact so here's what happened there's
an entrepreneur friend of mine he had
this successful business that he was
thinking do I sell it or do I just let
it run on autopilot sell it or let it
run on autopilot because he wanted to go
off and do something else he wanted to
leave the country join a different
business start something new and this
company that he created he was on the
fence whether he should just let it go
and sell it or go off and try to bring
somebody on who would just run it and he
could be on autopilot mode
the the Allure of passive income and
just everything is going to be done for
you automatically right anyway so I told
them you need to sell the business sell
it now sell it while you still have one
foot in the water sell it while you
still have some kind of care for the
company before you hate it because once
you're moving on and doing other things
any any involvement in this business is
going to be such a drain in the drag for
you you can't be in this thing you need
to move on and he hammed in her and I
wasn't sure and I I wasn't good at
closing him I wasn't I wasn't a good
enough Communicator to help him through
that decision because I knew that was
the right thing for him anyway he didn't
do it he didn't sell the business he
thought he's going to live this life you
know live overseas and have this
business run on autopilot and then the
business crashed
the business crashed because the
personality brought in didn't care as
much as he did wasn't the owner like he
was he wasn't there to make sure things
happened when crisis you know did happen
he wasn't super responsive and
eventually the business just fumbled
just just disintegrated just fell apart
even telling a story now brings me back
because
I see that as my responsibility because
he could have sold it and got a good
price it may not have been the price
that he wanted but it's way better than
just watching his business slowly tank
over time and I knew it was the best
answer for him and I didn't push hard
enough I didn't close him that this is
what he needed to do now you may be
watching saying well that's it's not
your responsibility it's his
responsibility you know he should have
known better you can only do so much and
yes at the end of the day I can't only
do so much and it's up to him to be able
to make that decision but I could have
done better right I could have done
better
I did not do my best because I didn't
know how to close I didn't learn the
skills
and as a result you know somebody close
to me suffered
and so I decided that I needed to get
better at it I needed to learn more I
needed to improve myself so that with
every entrepreneur that I meet I'm a
little bit better I'm A Little Bit
Stronger I can guide them just a little
bit better and if that my Improvement in
helping close them means that they have
a massive success because they decided
to take that path instead of going down
the wrong one because they were afraid
or greedy or whatever other reason
that's amazing
and if you want to influence people it's
the same thing if you want to help
people not just sell your product that
benefits you and doesn't benefit them
I'm not talking about using it for for
nefarious purposes right you want to
help people
you have to learn to close them
through through care through heart
through effort through energy
you have to learn how to close them if I
can't tell the difference between you
and all your competitors then the only
reason why I'm going to buy from you is
because you have a cheaper price you
don't want to win on being the cheapest
you're amazing you're a genius you have
Michael Jordan level talent and it's
time for the world to see it you need to
stop hiding so I remember not too long
ago I was in New York and I was meeting
with uh four more mentor of mine former
mentor of mine four more former Mentor
wow that's hard to say three times fast
former Mentor former Mentor former
Mentor okay got it yes meeting with a
former mentor of mine and he was asking
what my competitive Advantage was and I
said believe say believe what is that
like believe I want people to believe I
want to give people hope I want I want
people to have hope that's possible and
show them another way it's like hope you
can't be in the Hope business you're
selling hope what is that you're never
gonna win off a hope you can't win off
of believe that's just silly and you
know a younger version of me would have
felt man I don't know maybe he's right
here's this guy's had so much experience
and done so many things who am I to to
judge I don't know I've never done this
before
but the me who was listening to him was
like this guy just doesn't get it I'm
gonna Crush I feel like I already am I
already am crutches off believe people
stop me and say hey you're the believe
God yeah that's my mission yo that's
what I'm doing every day that's what I
wake up trying to spread it's the
world's biggest problem and I'm tackling
it I'm gonna make my dent in the
universe Steve right I'm gonna go make
my dent in the universe
that's my competitive advantage
and there may be people who don't
understand it and that's okay you can't
let their limited view of the world and
and super limited view of you prevent
you from going off and doing your thing
are you enjoying Evan
Evan you enjoying lying down on the
beach
[Music]
Heaven you look very comfortable
yeah
you gotta do what I gotta do
you gotta do what I gotta do how we
doing Evan
good how are you doing
I'm great I'm great Nina wants to do
this
how often
a lot a lot like a lot means like once
every three years no once a week wow
once a week
I'm getting stuff done let's go I like
the Heat
the heat is nice and listen there's heat
anywhere Nina goes
water's cold the water is cold Evan
holder than expected yeah
look who if I'm into
yeah
y'all just hanging out
Nina got bored so we left Tina got bored
so we left because I could have napped
it got bored that was fine you might got
four until he left I just wanted to go
for a walk I just want to go for a walk
at the beach
nice
[Music]
spend a little time with yourself
and and finish the sentence I am what I
am blank I am blank what's the blank you
are what if you're just by yourself you
have a little space to breathe from your
environment you are what what are some
of the words that come up what are some
of the positive words what are some of
the negative words that show up if
you're being honest with yourself
there'll be hope with some positive ones
so
um for me it could be I'm someone who
believes I am
I am a great husband
so I'm paying attention I am you know a
great father I am a great not owner what
do you do with dogs I don't know a great
deal consider your kids they're my kids
yeah they're kids pet kids all right you
know I am a bit down on the negative
size like I am uh afraid of
disappointing people I am scared of
speaking on stages I'm worried that I'm
gonna ask bad interview questions like
what are the positive and negatives if
you feel in the I am okay just to get
awareness of yourself this starts to
uncover some of the subconscious
behavior that you're living on autopilot
right the subconscious is the autopilots
what you're doing by default the
conscious of what we want to take
control of to then turn into
subconscious to then make
the automatic the positive the ambitious
the Bold the courageous right
so start with I am what that does is
lead you to step two which allows you to
identify your trigger words so what are
the trigger words that you use
consistently as an excuse for you not to
do the thing so my three trigger words
are scary difficult or hard that when I
say scary difficult hard
those used to be the reasons why I
couldn't do something those used to be
the reasons why I would let myself off
the hook those used to be the things I
would tell myself oh I can't do this
because it's scary I can't do this
because it's difficult I won't show up
because it's hard
and I would let myself off the hook for
those things that I would say oh that's
okay because it's scary so I'm not going
to do it
and and I would that would used to be my
identity the number one way to deal with
negative people in your life is through
empathy it's empathy it's not it's not
hating them back it's not spreading
negativity it's not reminding yourself
that you're better than them it's it's
empathy and it's not even just feeling
bad for them
it's actually connecting to them
let me let me explain
I default to assuming that people are
good this is a wild idea people are good
humans are good I've done the who
exercise the year one word exercise
helping people find the most important
core value with so many people and it's
always something positive
I believe that
99.99999999 of people are good there's a
tiny tiny tiny percentage of people who
enjoy killing people and maybe have you
know a few screws loose up here but for
the most part we're good everybody has
dreams everybody has Ambitions everybody
wants to serve everybody wants to be in
a better place than where they are right
now
the problem is
a lot of people are afraid a lot of
people are in pain a lot of people are
struggling a lot of people are suffering
a lot of people have tried they took
their shot and and it didn't work out
and because they're so in pain now they
don't want other people around them to
have success either
because if they took a shot and it
didn't work out
it's they don't want to own it that it's
on them but if you then go off and have
success you start achieving your goals
what does that say about them
right it's not that the world is rigged
against him it's that they actually suck
and they don't want to admit that and
they don't want to own up to that and so
they're living in pain
and so they take it out and other people
they take it out on you they take it out
on me they take it out on on the world
they take it out on people right that's
what that's what people do when they're
in a lot of pain think about you think
about your experiences your life think
about when you've been in a lot of pain
when you've struggled really think about
this the last time that you were
struggling in a lot of pain did you then
show up as your best self in all
situations
did you maybe lose your cool on somebody
did you maybe insult somebody did you
maybe say something that you're not
proud of that you later would regret has
it has that ever happened to you so that
you're a bad person it's not that you're
a toxic person it's not that you're a
hater
you were just in a lot of pain and so
the people who are throwing shade at you
are in a lot of pain they're struggling
and just recognizing that just trying to
put yourself in their shoes and look at
their life and if you know them you can
actually look at their life and if you
don't know them you can assume things
about their life if somebody's coming to
leaving a negative comment on your
YouTube video the fact that that is the
highlight of their day speaks volumes
about them right if the best part of
your day is going to somebody's YouTube
channel leaving some nasty comment that
gets you feeling good
you're in a lot of just imagine the pain
that that person's in imagine what their
life is like right now
and it's a bit of a mental exercise
because at the beginning the natural
reaction is to be defensive like well no
I'm not this and how could you call me
that
and we want the people around to support
us and cheer us on and tell us that
we're doing the right thing so the
natural
defense mechanism kicks in where we say
no I'm that's not that's not right but
if you take a breather you can take a
step back and you can just
try to have empathy try to put yourself
in their shoes try to see that they're
in a lot of pain what it does is removes
The Sting from the words it removes the
Venom from the words it doesn't get you
to react as emotionally it allows you to
show up more as your best self
it's it's one of the most valuable
things you can start to practice this is
one of the things that prevents people
from creating content from posting
videos from sharing their thoughts from
you've got a big mission a message your
story can change people's lives you your
story your story can change people's
lives it will change people's lives and
we're afraid to do it because of how
people that we don't know or people that
we do know will judge us
we're afraid that we're going to get
negative comments and that's the reason
why you're not putting your message out
there we have to learn you have to learn
to stop getting in your own way and to
start sharing to start releasing to
start living your life the life that you
want not somebody else's version of it
living in regret sucks
imagine you are 95 years old you're
looking back on your life at this moment
on this day realizing that you could
have played bigger you could have done
more you had more potential you had an
opportunity in front of you you could
have done something and you didn't you
didn't because you were afraid you came
up with some some reason that you
actually believed that was really an
excuse you played small you didn't
accomplish your goals now you're 95
years old and it's over and you can't do
it you're not physically or mentally
able to actually do it
the more you can actually feel that
that today matters that you want to stop
living your life by other people's
opinions and stop living with the fear
of regret
stop having that thing hang over your
head that you could have done something
and you were too afraid to do it the
more you can actually feel that it can
push you to actually take an action
because otherwise you live the life that
every Everybody lives that most people
live most people regret their life most
people regret not the things that they
did but the things that they didn't do
regret the ideas that you had then you
saw somebody else make a ton of money
off of you regret the conversation that
you wanted to take but you are too
afraid to go introduce yourself like we
live in this
zone of regret already you can feel it
look back to things that happened last
year two years ago or five years ago
like you wish that you showed up a
certain way you wish that you had more
courage more boldness and you didn't do
it you didn't do it and the point isn't
to beat yourself up over that the point
is to use that as courage to go do
something today towards accomplishing
your goals I used to use the fear of
regret a lot when I was when I was
younger especially to get myself to take
action the biggest decision of all the
hardest decision of all was to when I
was 19 not take the 100K a year dream
job that I thought I wanted to go become
an entrepreneur make 300 bucks a month
own 30 of a company that was the hardest
thing ever and the thing that gave me
the courage to do it was the fear of
regret
and Jeff Bezos has a great uh regret
minimization framework he calls it where
basically he tries to project out to
being you know that old old old old old
man and living life with as few regrets
as possible so I asked myself what will
I regret more
well I regret more saying no to my dream
job
and making six figures and travel around
the world or will I regret more saying
no to this business
and just not knowing
and I thought you know what I can always
go get another job
it may not be the same job it may not be
the same company may not be the same
opportunity may not be as much money it
may not be as much travel may not be
this perfect job but I could get another
similar job I felt like I could get
another similar job this business idea
this business opportunity I didn't know
that I would ever have this chance again
and so I said you know what even if the
most likely outcome is failure I didn't
think it was going to blow up I didn't
know that it was going to work out or
not even if the most likely scenario is
failure I still have to do it because I
don't want to live with regret and I
told myself I would rather know and fail
than not know catching that pattern it's
like oh it happened again again again I
wanted to go and do this and I didn't do
it again I had this opportunity to talk
to somebody and I played small again I
had this chance and I didn't do it and
you're gonna catch it
a day later a couple days later and
reflect back on it and realize okay I
should have done it next time I'm going
to try to have more awareness
step one is just the awareness game
because it's the problem is it's it's so
autopilot we play small by default
especially we've been doing it for
decades you play small by default so
it's so ingrained so natural so
autopilot that we have to slowly shift
out of autopilot Zone eventually what's
gonna happen is you're gonna catch it
in less than a day you're gonna catch it
a couple hours later they're gonna catch
it an hour later they're gonna catch it
10 minutes later they're gonna catch it
five minutes later and then step number
two is you're gonna get to this magical
moment you're going to get to this
magical moment where it's about to
happen you've caught it you've caught
your small thinking you've caught your
scared thinking you've caught your
excuses thinking
in the actual moment that it's happening
this is a magical spot right now because
you're actually calling yourself out on
your own BS right now and what you need
to do is get enough courage to actually
take the action to Pivot courses so
instead of doing what you historically
normally would do on autopilot now we're
going to take the other action the
action where you're proud of yourself
the action that you don't want to live
when you regret
that version of you showing up there's
an order to things it's a sequence to
things part of the problem with a lot of
entrepreneurs is they're just not doing
the things in the right order
you're trying to tackle that big mission
from the start
doing all 30 things at the same time
and not making any money and not make
any momentum not making any progress and
ultimately not have an impact that you
want to have
so out of your 30 ideas all inside your
mission amazing which one is actually
going to start getting you paid
because when you can start making money
everything becomes better everything
becomes easier you can quit your job you
can pay your bills you can hire a team
you can have a bigger impact right if
you had a team of 10 people versus you
doing things part-time on the weekends
and evenings
you're just gonna have a much bigger
impact if you have you working full time
in it and a team around you
how do you get there what's the one idea
of the 30.
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to watch another top 10 rules of
Evan Carmichael check out the video next
to me continue to believe I will see you
there the fastest way to achieve your
goals is to model the people who've
already achieved the same goals that you
have model success success excludes the
famous expression and it's true people
have already figured out the thing that
you are struggling to figure out